day five of software development week by
simply learn brings us to the advanced
java concepts
we hope all the previous sessions that
discuss the data structures and
algorithms c plus plus and core java
concepts were really helpful
we also understand that not everyone
made it and we believe in leaving no man
behind
so we have linked the videos in the
description box below hope you check all
the previous sessions getting into the
topic the advanced java covers the
complex parts of exception handling and
we dive deep into the java enterprise
edition java servless java api java jdbc
and much more
all these segments are proven to be used
in day-to-day programming and play a
vital role in software development
process
so without any further ado i would like
to hand the session over to our experts
to walk you through the advanced java
concepts
so we'll start off with understanding
what exactly is enumeration in java then
we'll continue with annotations in java
followed by that we have serialization
in java then we'll dive into
multi-threading in java next we have
synchronization in java and auto boxing
in java later we will discuss about
input and output streams in java
advancing ahead we have few more topics
that are java database connections that
is jdbc next we have generics in java
string handling in java and the
libraries which are java lang and java
util followed by that we will discuss
the networking in java next we have
images in java and concurrency utilities
for the next we have a few more topics
which are regular expressions in java
non-blocking input output or n i o in
java next we have java beans followed by
that we will enter into spring framework
next we have the spring model view
controller followed by that we have
spring and rest apis and finally we will
conclude this wonderful session with a
springboard project for a better
learning experience
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now we'll dive into the first
topic over to our training experts hello
guys this is vikesh and let's get
started with enums or enumerations or
enumerated types in java so before we go
into enums let's understand why we need
it
when you are building when you will be
building the java applications you will
face scenarios where you will have to
define some variables which will remain
constant forever for example months of
the year they are not going to change
they are always going to be 12 months in
an year
similarly let's say name of flowers they
are not going to change a lotus will be
a lotus forever similarly the name of
the seasons will always remain same the
season of summer or winter will always
be called summer or winter they will not
be changed the meaning of those
variables will never be overwritten or
will never be changed so you can think
of them as constants but they are not
the constants which your programs may
mutate or your programs may interpret
differently they will be interpreted by
multiple applications multiple
components multiple consumers in exactly
the same way similarly if you take the
example of time zones they are fixed
they work with the gmt with respect to
the gmt time zone and they will always
remain like that so if you have if you
whenever you have a situation where you
have to define such constructs or such
constants
always think of enum types or enumerated
types enum is basically a language
construct and you can use this language
construct to define type safe variables
when we say type safe variables what we
mean is that these variables
are not integer or string they are of
enum types that's the reason java
created a completely new data type which
is called the enum type
they are by default constant so you
cannot change them that's their property
and the way you define enums is like
this
you say public enum so instead of the
keyword class you use the keyword enum
and then you define the name of the enum
the name of the enum type and then you
define the possible values just simply
separating them by a comma
so for example days of the week is again
a constant thing there will always be
seven days of the week irrespective of
what you do on this planet
so that's why you can declare an enum
for the day and you can define those as
as the values
you also notice that the values are caps
by default and yes that is how you
define the enums
let's have a look at a more interesting
example of the enums in the ide now
so if i switch to the ide
i have created a class called color not
a class but an enum type called color
and this enum type color is basically
holding all the different color types
their values basically like all the
vibger colors for example so i've
defined three colors here which are red
green and blue
so you see i've defined them as caps
they automatically become bold you don't
have to bold them
but you see an interesting thing a
difference here that there is another
value in the brackets here this was not
there when we looked at this example of
day there is no value inside each of the
enum types but i have defined the value
of the enum types and that is optional
there will be use cases where you want
to define some enum constants where the
name of the enum type is a constant
which is a placeholder but it will have
an internal value which may be more
practical for your application so this
is what your consumers see and this is
what
is used whenever you call red inside
your application is just for simplicity
they would be they might be used cases
where you use some abbreviations and
their full forms for example if you want
to use here an abbreviation of let's say
wh o
and inside this you can define the value
as
world
health
organization so this is just a toy
example i'm giving you where you will
have use cases where you want to define
a constant but you want to define an
internal value of it which is to be read
by your application elsewhere but
everybody who wants to consume this enum
can just use this particular keyword and
if they want to get the value they can
get the value as well
so this is the use case where you might
need to define values of your enum types
as well but whenever you have to do that
if you want to fetch the value of an
enum type you have to write some extra
code which is written here if you were
not defining the value of your enum
types your enum can be as simple as this
you don't need to define anything else
apart from just defining the constant of
the enum types i'm giving a more complex
use case so that it covers both of the
things of using just the constants and
also using the values so if you just
want to read the constant you can just
say color.red or color.green or
color.blue in different classes and you
will be able to refer to the enum types
or use the enum types
but if you want to refer to the value of
the enum type then probably you need to
call this method called getvalue so
whenever you define a value what you
would do is you will define a private
member variable inside the enum which is
defined here you can name it anything if
you want
you define a constructor where you set
this particular value and then you
define a getter so whenever some
consumer application wants to refer to
the value of your enum type they can
call this getvalue method to get that so
this is the enum now let's see how we
can use this genome for using this enum
i have this main class where i have a
public static void main method and you
can simply fetch the enum types by
writing the code like this just write
the enum type holder and then type the
enum type so let me show you how this is
done if you just put a dot here you will
get all the enum type options so i've
defined three enum types red green and
blue and i get all the options so
whatever option i want to choose i can
just select here and i can store this
inside an enum variable
so if you want to just refer to the name
of the enum so this c1 is holding color
dot red or red so if you want to refer
to this just this red then you can call
the dot name method on the c1 variable
so if you say c1.name
it is going to put or print the red in
caps
and if you want to fetch the value
inside the red remember the value is
read in in small caps so if you want to
refer to the or if you want to fetch the
value of the red then you call the get
value method which we have defined here
so that's what we are doing here in this
first two sis outs where we are printing
the red enum name and then printing the
redinum value
now you can also iterate over all the
enum types
and for that you need to call the dot
values method on the enum so you can
just say color dot values which is going
to iterate over all the enum types
and you are just storing each of the
enum type in this color placeholder then
you can either call getvalue to get the
actual value of that enum type or you
can call the name to just print the name
of the enum as well
both of the options are available so
let's just put it back to get value and
let's run this code so if i run this
application i get some output here which
looks like this
first sis out says red enum name is red
in caps because we are calling the name
method
second says red enum value which prints
red in small because we are calling the
getvalue method and then we are
iterating over all the enums so i had
three enum variables here red green and
blue
and i'm going to iterate over all of
them one by one here printing their
value and not the enum constants
so that's why you see the red green and
blue here in small but if you just want
to print the enum constants themselves
and not their values then you change
this to dot name and then all the enum
constants will be printed here
so this is how you can create enums and
use enums for the constants which are
never going to change in your
application let's get started with
annotations in java now annotations is a
bit advanced concept so let's understand
why we need it there would be some cases
in your pro in your application where
you need to provide some metadata
information to the java compiler now
this sounds a bit complicated but it's
much simpler than that because you might
not want to code everything with lot of
lines of code rather you want to give
some smart instructions to the java
compiler so that they understand what to
do we have already seen some of the
annotations but the basic idea of
annotations is to provide some shorthand
metadata information about the program
to the java compiler generally
annotations will not have any direct
effect on the operation of the code they
annotate but they provide additional
logic to the code that's the idea with
annotation remember they are shorthand
metadata the main use is providing
information to the compiler or providing
some compile time or deployment time
processing or also providing some
instructions for runtime processing we
have already seen some of the
annotations if you remember when we were
dealing with inheritance we had this add
the rate override over the methods right
this add the rate override is an
annotation this annotation if you if i
if i show you what i'm talking about if
i take you back to one of the
inheritance example or the method
overriding examples and if i open the
mountain bike class here mountain bike
extends bicycle you will see this
override annotation this is an
annotation an annotation always starts
with at the rate in java and the
annotation name is overwrite now this
override is just a shorthand to tell the
compiler that hey i am overriding this
method from the base class that's what
this annotation does if you remove the
annotation in some cases the java
compiler might not understand what to do
and the java compiler has to do some
extra processing to figure out that this
method is actually being overridden but
if you put this at override here then
the java compiler pre-hand will know
that this is coming from the base class
so you save some of the compiler
processing time as well by using the
annotation it's a shorthand providing
instructions to the compiler you see
exactly what i'm talking about so this
is one of the annotations which we have
used but we will look at some of the
other more generic annotations and we
will also see how we can build our own
custom annotation in java you might have
also seen some other annotations like
for example you can put aggregate
suppress warning annotation which is a
very popular annotation to suppress any
kind of yellow warnings in your code
generally we do not recommend doing that
but if you have a use case then you can
use at direct suppress annotation as
well there are some other annotations as
well like advert author if you want to
put your name as the author of a
particular piece of code then you can
add this metadata so that whenever
somebody looks at even the documentation
of your code your name will be shown
there as the author so that's the idea
with annotations so let's see how you
can build your own custom annotation
whenever you have to do that there are
multiple ways to doing that and the
first type of annotation we are going to
have a look at is called marker
annotation a marker annotation is just
an empty annotation without having any
metadata logic at all you can see it is
i have defined an annotation here i will
talk about what is all this means but
inside the block there is no code here
and this is how you define a marker
annotation marker annotation is just to
provide very high level instructions to
the compiler and the way you will write
your custom annotation is you will put
an access modifier keyword like public
then you will write add the rate
interface this is the keyword which you
have to use whenever you are trying to
create your custom annotation marker or
no marker doesn't matter whenever you
define your annotation you have to use
add great interface once you do that
then you provide a name for your
annotation which can be anything but
still not complete we need to also
provide more instructions to the
compiler or the runtime processor to
tell them when to execute this
annotation and what the annotation type
is going to be applied upon so at first
you specify when this annotation is
going to be active or executed or
evaluated so here you can say add the
rate retention which is another
annotation so you say add direct
retention and then you say retention
policy dot whatever you want to write as
you can write it as runtime or you can
write it as source if you write it as
source then it is going to be applied at
compile time and if you select it as
runtime then the annotation is going to
be processed at runtime so this is the
first thing which you need to provide
the second thing which you need to
provide is where this annotation is
going to be applied whether you want
this annotation to be applied to a class
or to a method or to a member variable
or to any other type and that's what you
define in the add the rate target
annotation you specify the target
audience for this particular annotation
and here inside the element type you
will get multiple options you can apply
this annotation to a constructor to a
field local variable method module
package record component type etc so
here i'm going to use type which means
it can be applied to a class or a
generic element type which generally
means class type and that's all you can
define your marker annotation like this
but generally these marker annotations
does not have any logic so you will not
get much value out of it until you have
very special cases but if you have a
case where you want to also run some
business logic or provide some metadata
logic to the compiler while defining the
annotation then you can define the
annotation like this so i've created one
more annotation here which is called
which is called my custom annotation
again the target audience for this is
method so this annotation can only and
only be applied to methods if you try to
apply this annotation to a class you
will get an error the retention policy
is run time it means it is going to be
processed at runtime and i've declared a
method here which is called hint value
so this is how you will declare your
annotation now let's see how do you how
do you use this annotation so i have a
class called as my class here and if you
look at this structure of the my class
we create the class and then i create a
method which is named as sayhello and i
am applying this annotation on this
particular method remember the target
audience of this particular annotation
was method so it only be applied a
method if i try to put this on the class
type here then i get an error here it
says the annotation my custom annotation
is disallowed at this location because
the type specified is of type method so
the compiler will not allow you to use
this at an illegal place so you write
any method and you apply your annotation
but you provide a value to the method
the int value method is going to consume
this value and inside the method you can
write any other logic so let's see how
this pans out i create a public static
void method and i create an object of my
class so my class h equal to new my
class and after that i'm saying h dot
get class dot get method i'm basically
calling the method by using reflection
api you can also call the method
directly if you want but this is how you
need to call it if you want to use the
annotation property value if you want to
fetch the value of the annotation so
this is just an example of me showing
you how you fetch the annotation so we
created an object and then we say get
class which is going to return my class
type and then get method is going to
return the method type which has the
name say hello so this is a way to fetch
a method name or a method type from a
class using java's reflection api which
is an advanced api you might you might
not need to use it but for the sake of
demo i'm using this so we fetch the
class and we fetch the method it is
going to search the class for a method
name say hello if it finds the method it
is going to return the method in this
variable and then you can call method
val which was this variable dot get
annotation give me any annotation which
is applied on this particular method and
you supply the annotation class type as
well once you do that you get a my
custom annotation reference type and
then if you call the value method on
this you will get this value as 10. so
this is a way where you can apply an
annotation and you can actually see the
effect of the annotation you might not
always want to do this because like i
said these are metadata instructions to
the compiler but if you have a need to
actually see what your annotation is
doing you can use the getclass.get
method to first fetch the method store
it into a method type and then call get
annotation supplying the exact
annotation class type and then you can
call the exact method which is defined
in your annotation here i've defined it
as value so i'm just calling the value
method so if i run this particular
example i get the value as 10. so i'm
able to see or fetch the exact value
which my annotation metadata is holding
at the runtime and this is the power of
annotation they're a very powerful
concept and they're a very advanced
concept they would be very rare
scenarios in your application where you
need to create your custom annotations
generally you will be better off will
with your with your predefined
annotations which are provided in java
like at the rate override and the red
author at the rate
suppress warning etc let's get started
with serialization in java now before we
go further let's understand why we need
the concept of serialization when you
will be building the enterprise grid
applications in in different
organizations you will often have a use
case or a need to send an object from
one application to other application
which is deployed on some other machine
so if you have a network of computers or
if you have a lot of different uh
complex setup where you need you have a
producer application and you have a
consumer application producer
application produces the object and then
this object gets traveled over the
network lines over the network wires and
reaches at the consumer application and
how does the consumer application
receive the object and how does the
producer application sense the object
because when the data travels over the
network lines it will be all bytes so
how do you convert a java object into
bytes send it over network and then the
consumer application has to again
convert that bytes back to an object
representation and then store that or
use that inside its application so you
need to do this whole conversion right
so the process of converting an object
to a byte so that it can be sent over a
network is called serialization and the
process of converting back the byte from
the byte from the network to a java
object is called deserialization so
generally you you may have a use case
where you serialize an object create a
binary representation of it send it over
the network and that's where the java
serialization concept kicks in whenever
whenever you have to do this in java you
will be using the serializable interface
so you need to extend your objects from
this serializable interface so that
those objects themselves becomes
serializable you need to tell java that
this object is able to serialize itself
and deserialize itself and the way you
will tell java is by letting that object
implementing the serializable interface
let's have a look at an example for of
this serialization and deserialization
to understand this concept better so
here again i've used the same student
class where it has the name age and
address so you can see i have created a
student class but the student class
implements serializable this is
something which you have to add to your
class
second thing the moment you do that all
the modern day ides like eclipse or
intellij will ask you to add a serial
version universal id to this particular
class this is added so that java can
uniquely identify your object once it is
serialized and deserialized and it will
also keep a versioning track of it right
because when you serialize the object
what happens if somebody hops over the
network line and change the
representation of your object and the
consumer application will get a
completely different object copy now so
this is java's way to make sure that the
same version which the producer
application is producing is received by
the consumer application so it's also
sort of a security feature it basically
whenever you do an update onto the
object it is going to increment this
serial version uid by one so when you
create the object first time and you
serialize it for for the very first time
the value is going to be set as default
one and as you mutate the object again
and again before deserializing it the
count will just keep on increasing so
that's how you keep a track of the state
of the object which is being serialized
by adding this long serial version uid
you can also specify your own value if
you want to by default java initializes
a value of 1 and this is a long type
variable so that is the only new thing
which is happening the moment you do
implement serializable after that i have
the same fields here i have the
constructor and the setters and the
getters
and i also have a tostring method just
to print the object nicely where i print
the name
the age and the address
so let's look at a main class and where
we use the student object we serialize
this object and then we deserialize this
object so what is happening here is
i create a class i create the main
method and i create a student object
this is something which we have already
seen then i
want to store the state of this object
when you serialize this object this
object has to be either sent to a
network but since i'm running this demo
on the same machine what i will do that
i will serialize this object onto my
local file system it's the same thing
right you can put it somewhere and then
fetch it from there so either you can
send it over the network or you can put
it on a file system so i create the
object and then i need to store this
into a file so far i have not covered
the file handling operations so we will
not go deeper into the file handling
classes here but i will just explain you
the reasoning for it and when we'll do
the file handling session there i will
go in detail about the file handling
classes so i specify your file name
where the serialized representation of
my student object is going to be stored
and this is the location where i'm
supposed to store this then i create two
different classes which is for writing
to the file and then creating an object
for it so that's what i'm doing here we
can ignore this particular part where
i'm just supplying the file name and we
can focus on this part this line where
i'm saying write the object the student
object to this particular file that's
what i'm doing here in this particular
in this three lines of code that i'm
writing the student object to the file
so when java has to write this object to
the file it is automatically going to
serialize it that's the only way java
can write an object to the file so you
serialize the object and then you print
that message that the object has been
serialized again you can ignore this
part as well like i said we will not
focus on this but what we technically
did is we just wrote we just wrote the
object to a file by serializing it then
i try to deserialize it so i load the
file load this same file into the java
jvm and then i read the object and the
way i read the object is by using this
object input stream class i supply the
file that read this particular file and
then i call the read object method which
is going to return an object a general
object when you call the read object
method the read object method does not
know that it is a student type object so
you so you need to explicitly cast this
to the student type so that you can
store this as a student object if you do
not cast this you will get an error
because like i said read object does not
know anything about the student class so
what does what does this mean is that
when you serialize an object the class
type information is lost you cannot
store the class type information when
you serialize an object because the
moment you call this write object method
from the object output stream class so
you created this object output stream
class you supply the file output
location and you call the right object
the moment you call the right object
it's just any java object for the this
java program the signature of the
student class is lost it does not know
that it's a student class anymore once
it has been once it is being serialized
similarly when you deserialize it the
serialization api has no idea about what
student class is and what student object
is so you need to tell the read object
method explicitly that hey you are
reading an object of the student type
and that's how this line works once you
explicitly provide the casting operation
once you have casted it we try to print
the same deserialized object to see if
all the state which we stored in the
object is still persisted there or not
when we deserialize it so our major
focus in this particular class is this
object output stream classes and the
right object method these are the two
most important statements which you need
to take care of the file output stream
is basically a file location what is an
output stream we will talk about that
later but
the whenever you need to serialize you
need to use this particular class called
object output stream so that's all i'm
doing here i'm serializing the object
with this these values and then i will
deserialize and i will again print the
object to see if these values are still
there or not so let's run this
application so when i run this
application let's start from here first
this out gets called which says object
has been serialized so you see object
has been serialized and what i
serialized was this student object which
had the value of name as john age as 25
and the address as 23 east california
and that's what gets printed here then
this whole block gets completed this
whole try block gets completed it's a
standard try catch block you see i have
also added the i o exception you need to
do that because these file operations
will force you to catch or throw the i o
exception which is a checked exception
that's why it will force you to do that
then we move to the deserialization
block where we create an object of the
object input stream class and then we
call the read object we cast it to the
student type and then we print the
object so when i print this object this
line gets printed object has been
deserialized and then i can see that the
exact same state is still there the name
which is set in the object is still
there after being after being
deserialized the age and the address is
exactly intact so this is how we you can
serialize an object send it anywhere you
want and then the consumer application
need to read the object and cast it back
to the student type and they will be
able to see the exact same state which
you saved in the object just before
serializing it what if you have a use
case where you do you have a property in
up in a student class or in your object
but you do not want that to be
serialized that's also a use case where
you may have 50 different properties
inside the student class and one of the
properties something which you do not
want to serialize because you do not
want the consumer application to see
that value if you ever had that scenario
use the transient variable so transient
is again a keyword and the moment you
put this keyword in front of a member
variable that variable becomes transient
the use case of transient variable is
that if you do not want this x to be
serialized and deserialized then you put
the transient keyword in front of it the
normal member variables will
automatically get serialized and
deserialized when the object is
serialized and deserialized but if you
have a use case where you do not want a
particular member variable to be
serialized or deserialized put transient
in front of it and then have the getters
and setters for this x variable and
let's use this and see if this actually
gets serialized or not so i created the
student object and let me call
student
dot
set x and let's put a value to x let's
say 10. so i have said the value of x is
10 and x is a transient variable and
then i am serializing the whole object
here and then i'm deserializing the
object and let's see if i'm able to
fetch the value of x after d serializing
the student object so i'm calling the
system.out.println and the d serialized
value of x is
object
dot
get x
let's see if i'm able to see the value
of x or not so let's run this
application again
so this is exactly the same as before
this is also exactly the same as before
but i see the value of x is 0. remember
i set the value as 10 before serializing
it but i don't see the value 10 anymore
when i deserialize the object because it
was transient if you remove transient
from it then you will be able to
transfer or travel this value of 10
between serialization and
deserialization so if i just remove this
here don't change anything at all and i
just rerun the application this time
when i deserialize the object the value
of x as 10 is still present there even
after deserialization so this is how you
can use the transient variables if you
want to
not have that object serialized or
deserialized when you're doing the
serialization let's get started with
concurrency and threads the reason i
want to talk about concurrency because
once we understand about the concurrency
it will become much more simpler to talk
about threats and the idea behind
concurrency is very simple and plain and
that idea is that as a developer when
you write a program you would expect the
machine or the computer to run multiple
tasks in parallel for example right now
i'm recording this video on on a
particular laptop which is recording my
voice which is also recording the screen
which is also running the eclipse ide
and also running a chrome browser it is
also have it also have opened multiple
background applications so there are a
lot of tasks running in parallel at the
same time and that's the idea about
concurrency now how do we work with
concurrency in java is with the help of
processes and threads so these are the
two basic units of execution when we
talk about concurrent programming in
java and when we talk about processes
you can think of a process as basically
an execution environment or i should
call it as a stand-alone execution
environment think of a logical box which
is completely cut out from everything
and it has its own environment for
example again the recording software is
running it's in its own execution
environment and when we talk about
process process generally has an
everything or a private set of all the
runtime resources it needs and the
memory space it needs now there is
another concept or another construct
which is very important is threads so
threads are also sometimes called
lightweight processes and basically when
we talk about threads it's a thread also
has an execution environment but
creating a new thread requires lot less
resources than creating a new process
and you can also think of threads as a
mini version of a process because a
process can have multiple threads
remember that statement that a process
can have multiple threads threads always
exist within a process and whenever you
start a process there will be at least
one thread attached to it and each
thread is basically a task for example
the voice recording can be a process and
inside that the mic recording
expression or the mic recording or task
can be run by a particular thread let's
take another example that when you play
games let's say you are playing a racing
game so when you play the racing game
there are multiple things happening at
once you see the current speed of your
car or bike on the screen you also see
your leaderboard position what ranking
you have in the race currently you also
see some other kind of features like
players health or the car's health or
the fuel
consumption available and lots of other
stuff the graphics the motorcycle the
other comp other competitors bikes and
their speeds and their distance to you
as well so if you see all of these are
running are different threads there's a
different thread to show your current
speed there's a different thread to show
the current leaderboard position there's
a different thread to show the fuel
indicator etc everything is running in a
different thread so all of these threads
need to run at the same time in your
program for a complete immersive user
experience and that's what we mean when
we say multi-threading that we want
multiple threads to run at the same time
to create a better experience in the
application so that's the basically the
theoretical part of it please do read
about more about how threads work and
how processes work and there's a lot
more documentation available in the java
docs as well when we talk about threads
but i will keep the theoretical part to
this particular point and now we will
move to an
eclipse example to see how we can create
threads so with that let's move to the
eclipse ide and here i have a demo
prepared basically so what i have here
is a threading demo class which has a
public static void main method and it
has a simple for loop and inside the for
loop i see this strange code here where
i am initializing two threads and
starting them so that's all i'm doing
here but let's see how this thread one
and thread two class have been written
and why do i see two different ways of
initializing them let's go deeper into
this now so let's see how thread one can
be created so first of all you can
create a thread by just creating a
simple class but make sure that you
extend it with the pre-built thread
class this thread class is from coming
from java so from the jdk basically so
the moment you extend your normal class
from the thread class then you will have
to override the run method so if i show
you the thread class here this is the
thread class
implementation available inside the jdk
and this is the class which is getting
called when you are extending is from
the thread class and this thread class
will ask you to override a run method
here the override annotation is missing
so let me just add this for better
understanding so you need to overwrite
the run method and this is something
which you need to do so that you can
specify what happens when you run the
thread so this run method will be called
whenever the thread is running at this
particular point i would also like to
tell you that there are different states
in the thread so there is a thread which
says thread is ready then there is a
state which is which say thread is
running there is also a state where the
thread is waiting for an i o input from
the user from the console or the command
line there can also be a state which
says dead where the thread has completed
its task and it's not working there can
also be a state which is called sleep
state where the thread is paused so
there are different states of the thread
and in this example we are going to
focus primarily on three states which is
the ready state and the running state
and the completed state so when you call
the run method the thread state is going
to change to running and whatever code
you write inside this particular run
method will be the logic which this
particular thread is supposed to execute
here i'm just putting a dummy logic
where i'm just
printing assist out but definitely if
you try to create your threads this will
contain your actual business logic for
example that fuel indicator code or for
the leaderboard position code will go
inside this run method and then i'm
catching an exception if there's an
exception but obviously there will not
be an exception coming in because i have
nothing here literally so that's what we
are we are doing when we are creating
this thread one class and let's come
back to the threading demo now so to
initialize a thread or initialize might
not be right word to run a thread the
first thing which you need to do is to
initialize the class containing the run
method so i would avoid calling this
class as thread because technically this
is just a class so you initial so you
basically create an object of the thread
just like you create the object of any
other class there is nothing new here
right so we just say new thread 1 and
then we call t1 dot start now if you
observe carefully there is no start
method here we just had a run method but
this code is still compiling fine and
i'm calling the start method here
because the start method is the internal
method of the thread class which in turn
is going to call the run method so you
are never going to invoke the run method
directly you just need to start the
thread which is going to change the
state of the thread from ready to
running so this start method has the
responsibility of changing the state to
running and the way the start method is
going to do that is by calling the run
method internally inside the jdk itself
from developer perspective you just need
to call the start method and that's it
the thread will start running and
whatever is present in the run method
will get executed so that's the way to
start the thread second thing i have one
more thread created here which is the
thread 2 class so in this case when i
create a thread 2 class i am not
extending it from the thread class
rather i am implementing the runnable
interface here so this is a different
interface available which is a
functional interface which means it will
have just one method which is the run
method but the interesting thing is that
here when i created thread one i said
extends thread but here when i'm
creating the second thread i'm not using
extends thread but i'm using implements
runnable let's understand why do we do
that first of all the reason java
provides two different ways of creating
threads is because there might be a use
case that you need to extend your thread
to class from some of your custom java
class remember java does not support
multiple inheritance so at a time you
can only extend this class from one
class so what if there was no runnable
interface and you need to extend this
thread to from student class let's say
so you need to do class thread to
extends
student for example the student is not
present here but let's assume it is so
you do this and then you also have to
extend it from thread now java doesn't
support multiple inheritance and this
will not work so what would you do if
you have to also create it as a thread
but also extend it from some of your
parent class you will not be able to do
that and that's the reason java provides
the implements runnable because then you
can extend it from any of your super
class of your interest and at the same
time also implement implement it with
runnable interface so that you can treat
this class as a thread so that's the
reason java provides two different ways
of creating threads remember that it's a
very important concept and once you
implement runnable again it will ask you
to override the run method so i will
just put override annotation here so
once you override the run method again
you can write whatever logic you want
this particular thread to execute inside
the run block coming back to the main
class so
when you are extending from thread the
initialize initialization is very simple
where you create the object and you call
the start method on the object but if
you are creating a thread by
implementing the runnable interface the
initialization of the thread is a bit
different and it's different in this
particular part on the left hand side
you still say thread t2 remember you are
saying thread and not thread two this is
a this is the java thread class this is
the jdk thread class not your own thread
class so you say thread t2 then you say
new thread and inside the new thread you
provide your own class type thread 2 was
your own class type so you specified
your own custom thread class here inside
the new thread constructor this thread
class is the jdk class if you click on
this you will see this is from the jdk
class so that's the difference extending
thread simple initialization
implementing runnable interface do the
initialization like this and after that
you call the the similarly the start
method which is in turn going to call
the run method so that was how you
create threads differently and now let's
run this program to understand how the
output looks like when we run these
threads in loops remember i am
initializing 10 instances of each of
these threads so in total there would be
20 output lines so if i go to run as
java application i see this output here
so let's observe this output for once so
thread 1 thread 2 is running in sequence
in the first time but then you see
thread 1 is running twice and then
thread 2 is running twice then again you
see a good sequence but again thread 2
has run twice here again thread 1 has
run twice if i go further down thread
one runs once then again thread two runs
twice thread one runs once thread two
runs once so there is no particular
order here though based on the code
which we have written we should expect
thread one is running from here and then
thread two is running output from here
in a sequential fashion but we don't see
the sequential fashion here and this is
the power of concurrency this is because
threads never run in sequence they run
in parallel and which thread will
execute first you can't really predict
that so it's so be very careful when you
whenever you're writing multi-threading
code because you cannot predict the
sequence of execution because threads
are going to run whenever they find the
idle cpu so the key is the idle cpu
whenever a thread finds an idle cpu it
is going to occupy that cpu and going to
run its own execution and the moment its
execution finishes the other thread will
jump in and take up and take a piece of
the cpu so whichever thread gets the
idle piece of the cpu is going to
execute and that is the reason you see
this randomized output the next time you
are going to run you will see a
different random order so this time you
see thread one ran four times you did
not see this in the previous execution
if you run it again you will see again a
different output this time the thread
one run thrice so every time you will
run this you will see a different
sequence there is no guarantee of order
because the threads are running in
parallel and they're running whenever
they get the idle cpu that's the bottom
line so this is how we are going to
create threads and remember you cannot
guarantee the sequence of the execution
so write your code accordingly and use
the threads for independently running
parallel threads which do not depend
upon each other let's get started with
thread synchronization in java so in the
previous example we saw that when we
execute threads then we can't guarantee
the sequence but it's actually
technically not a problem in the example
which we had look at before but it can
become a bigger problem when two threads
are trying to access the same object
remember object has properties and state
so what if the first thread modified the
object state and the second thread is
reading the state of the object the
second thread is expecting the original
state but while it was trying to read it
the other thread modified its state so
you can see this become a this can
become a big problem for example if you
are working with a banking system and if
there are two persons accessing the same
account at the same time one is
depositing the money and one is
withdrawing the money from the account
and if the total balance is thousand and
if both of them deposit 500 and withdraw
500 at the same time then who sees what
and if these are two if these are
handled by two different threads then we
can't guarantee if somebody sees a 1500
as the total sum or somebody sees a 500
as a total sum or there can be a
scenario where somebody sees zero as the
total sum so it there so the application
can turn into really weird scenarios if
two threads are trying to change the
state of a particular object at the same
time and java provides a solution of it
with the concept of intrinsic locks and
synchronizations so the idea is that
when a thread tries to work on a
particular object it basically takes a
lock on that particular object we also
call this as an intrinsic lock or
monitor lock so it takes a lock on the
object and it means that that particular
object becomes completely inaccessible
to other threads in the system at that
particular time so the moment you put
synchronization or you put lock on a
particular object only the thread which
has taken the lock will be able to
access the object and other threads will
be forbidden from accessing the object
so that's the idea behind intrinsic
locks and synchronization so that was
about the brief theory of it now let's
have a look at a practical example so i
have prepared another example for it so
here i have again created two threads
but these two threads it's the pretty
much the same threads which we covered
in the previous
session named as thread one and thread
two one is extending thread class and
other is implementing runnable but
that's the that's same but the
interesting part is this both of them
have a reference to a class called
mathutils if you see thread 1 also has
the reference and thread 2 also has the
reference and what the math utils is
doing here is basically you supply a
number and it prints the multiples of it
till five so for example if you supply
two you will get the output two four six
eight ten if you supply three you will
get the multiple of 3 up to 3 times 5 so
3 6 9 12 15. if you supply 4 you will
get the outputs of the in the multiples
of 4 till 20. so whatever number you
will supply you will get the next 5
multiples of that particular number
that's what this class is doing and
another thing which interesting thing
which i've done here is this thread dot
sleep which means that when you run this
loop where you are printing the
multiples till five of that number every
time you do the first multiplication
then you sleep for 400 milliseconds and
when i say sleep it basically means the
current thread is going to pause its
execution for 400 millisecond and it is
going to leave the cpu idle and if there
is another thread running currently in
the system that thread will get the
share of the cpu for that 400
millisecond and once the 400
milliseconds is finished the thread is
going to wake up and it is again going
to hunt for the idle cpu to pick up and
start doing its execution so that thread
dot sleep happens for 400 milliseconds
at every step of this iteration in this
for loop so thread one is going to use
this particular method of this
particular class and it is going to ask
the class to print the multiples of 2
and thread 2 is also going to access the
reference of the class and access the
get multiples method but this thread
asks to print the multiple of three so
thread one asks for printing the
multiples of two up to two times five
and thread two wants to print the output
to multiple sub three up to three times
five so that's the basic scenario two
threads accessing the same object
supplying different values and expecting
the output so if i run this demo as is
without any change here i'm just
initializing the math utils class
initializing two threads and then
calling the start only once so if i run
this particular program i see get i see
this strange output that even when i
said t1 dot start first so t1 was
holding the multiple of 2 remember but i
still get 3 first then 2 then 4 6 so
multiples of 2 gets executed here but
then the other thread takes the cpu and
it starts running its own multiples
outputs and you see nine printing first
and then six gets printed then twelve
then eight then fifteen and then ten at
very last so the output looks very
random it would have been nicer if i
could have seen 2 4 6 at 10 once and
then 3 6 9 12 15 once if i see them in
different sections in different
sequences that would have been so nice
because then i know which thread is
running when and when that particular
thread is working on the object so i'm
just trying to replicate the same
scenario where two threads are accessing
the same object at the same time but
they are executing the object randomly
they are changing the state of the
object randomly here so how do we fix
this to fix this we can put so we have
this get multiples method which is the
bone of contention here this is the
method which is being randomly accessed
so what i can do here that i can put
synchronized keyword in front of the
method so once you put the synchronized
keyword in front of the method which is
being accessed by multiple threads at
the same time this method this whole
method gets synchronized now what this
means that one thread will be execute
this method at once there will never be
a scenario where two threads are
simultaneously executing this get
multiples method or even getting a hold
of this get multiples method at the same
time there would be only one thread at a
time executing this method so if i put
the synchronized here and if i rerun
this example you see i get a more
streamlined output if you notice
everything is one running like clockwork
where first the thread one gets executed
so i get 2 4 6 8 10 really well printed
and then the second thread starts which
says 3 6 9 12 15. the reason i get this
output is because when i did t1 dot
start it immediately went to execute the
get multiples method but it's so
synchronized there so it took a lock on
the method and even when the t2.start
might have got executed maybe
milliseconds after that or nanoseconds
after that it still could not get hold
of the getmultiples method because
thread one occupied this particular
method it took a lock on this particular
method due to the synchronized keyword
so that's the power of synchronized
keyword that you can take a lock on a
particular method if you put it in front
of the method now there can be scenarios
that you do not want to lock the whole
method you still want two different
threads to access the method but there
can be very few lines of code inside the
method which is that which is thread
sensitive code now how do you spot
thread sensitive code there is no magic
bullet there is no silver bullet for it
and it comes with experience so you need
to have that experience to know which is
the thread sensitive code which can
create problems if two threads run that
code at the same time so the moment you
have spotted that code and if you don't
want to lock the whole method you can
lock the exact lines of code by putting
the synchronized block so if i remove
this and i enable this particular part
so what i'm doing that i know that this
is the code which is exactly causing the
problem which is creating this random
output so what i can do that i can put
the synchronized keyword right before
the block of the code starts which is
thread sensitive and the way you do that
is you write synchronized and you supply
this which means whoever has the current
who whoever has the object of the math
he builds that whole object gets locked
for this particular block of code so
whoever has the mathews object takes the
lock on the object for this particular
block of code if there were some other
code which was written in the get
multiples method before the synchronized
block or after the synchronized block
that block can be accessed by multiple
threads at the same time but this code
will only be accessible to one thread at
a time there will never be there will
never be a concurrent access to the
synchronized block that's the power of
synchronized block and it will work the
exact same way so to show you if i run
this particular program i still get the
output in the same streamline way where
first the multiples of two get printed
and then the multiples of three get
printed so that's how you can actually
use synchronized methods or synchronized
block to make sure that one thread is
accessing a sensitive object at a time
and there will never be a scenario that
two threads are mutating the same object
at the same time again like i said be
very very cautious of when you use
synchronized blocks and when you use
threads because threads have
unpredictable execution cycle execution
sequence basically and synchronized
blocks also have problems if you have if
you have thousands and thousands of
threads running in your application and
if you put synchronized on a particular
method your application may face severe
performance issues because all of the
threads will be executing that method in
a sequence imagine you put this on to a
huge application or a huge ecommerce
application or a news website it is it
is going to create serious performance
issues so be very cautious of how and
when you use synchronized method and the
key to that is to have that developer
dna to spot the code which is causing
this problem which might be thread
sensitive and maybe you might need to
change the code itself you might not
need to go into the multi-threading
scenario and you might you might be able
to fix it without using the threading or
synchronized concept it completely
depends but always have a good trade-off
when to use the synchronized methods and
synchronize blocks let's get started
with auto boxing and unboxing in java so
if you remember in the very first
sessions i talked about the primitive
data types and then later on we talked
about the objects for example we had the
int data type but there later we also
saw an integer data type which is which
can also pretty much do the exact same
work which int data type was doing and
we saw the similar kind of uh experience
for the float data type and the float
class double data type and the double
class care data type and the character
class and so on so forth so java
provides an easy way to convert a int
data type variable into an integer data
type variable and also back from integer
data type variable to an int primitive
data type variable now you might be
wondering why we need that there would
be scenarios for example if you had an
int array as in primitive int array and
if you want to store that into a
collection now collection can only be of
type of objects it cannot be a type of
primitive data type so you might need to
convert this int primitive data type
array into an integer object collection
so you need to do this conversion of
into data type to integer data type and
there would be cases where you invited
you might need to do vice versa so
that's the basic idea about auto boxing
and unboxing so when we talk about the
definition you can see auto boxing is
the automatic conversion that the java
compiler makes between the primitive and
their corresponding object wrapper
classes so whenever you are converting a
primitive data type to an object class
this is called autoboxing and when you
do the reverse it is called auto
unboxing or simply unboxing so let's
understand this with the help of an
example now so i'm just going to open an
example about auto boxing and unboxing
so that we can have a look at it and
here it is i've created a class which is
called auto boxing demo it has a public
static void main method and inside the
method i'm first simply declaring an int
data type variable i with the value 10.
then if i need to autobox this if i need
to convert this primitive value into an
integer object wrapper class or an
integer class type then i need to write
the code like this which says integer
dot value of and then you can supply the
primitive data type value and the output
of it will be of type integer class so
you get an integer object and then you
can print the object to check if it is
successfully doing the auto boxing or
not similarly doing the other way round
once i have converted this into an
integer object let's convert this back
to a primitive data type so from integer
object i'm converting this back into the
primitive data type and you see here
it's a simple assignment i just have to
assign the object to the primitive data
type and that's it i can do the same for
a character
object and a cad data type so first i
create a character object
obj and then if i have to unbox it i can
simply assign this cad obj to a care
primitive data type ch and that would be
it so you can do the similar drill for
any other primitive to object wrapper
conversion let's say you want to convert
a floats data type to a float class or
you want to convert a double data type
to a double class then whichever
primitive data type has an object
wrapper class you can do the auto boxing
and auto unboxing like this remember
whenever you have to do auto box it
means you're going from primitive to
object and for that you need to call the
value of method for example if you were
converting a double primitive to a
double object classically then you are
going to call double dot value off and
similarly the same kind of behavior will
be seen for other object wrapper classes
as well so for auto boxing you call the
value off and for auto unboxing you
literally just assign this to an
primitive and the object wrapper class
value will automatically be assigned to
the primitive data type so let's run
this now and observe the output so i had
the int i equal to 10 then i wanted to
convert this primitive into the object
wrapper and the way i can do that is by
calling the value of method and
supplying the primitive data types value
so that's why i'm doing it that's what
i'm doing here and this i obj
should get the 10 value now which i can
see if i print the cis out and if i just
print the integer object all together i
get the value 10 so this concludes that
i've successfully am able to
auto box the primitive into an integer
object now looking at auto unbox like i
said you simply can assign the object
wrapper to the primitive data type
variable and that should work as is and
that's why at line 15 we get this output
which says value of i1 is 10. similarly
when we try to auto box the character
object so i have created a character
object here and then i want to unbox
this back into a simple car data type ch
so when i print ch i get the same value
and when i print the car obj i again get
the same value remember the reason i've
put this as auto box is because this by
default is being stored into a car data
type i can also write it like this for
example i can say care x equal to a and
then i can refer here as character
dot value of x this will pretty much
have the same impact or the same effect
which i had just now it is going to
print the exact same output if i read on
this program i'm going to get the exact
same output so this this basically
concludes our understanding that you can
use the auto boxing and auto unboxing
pretty easily whenever you have a
scenario where you want to convert the
primitive data types to the object
wrapper classes or you want to convert
the object wrapper classes back to the
primitive data types let's get started
with io in java or io streams in java so
when we say io it basically means input
output and the basic idea is that your
program takes an input and gives you an
output so whenever you have to do some i
o handling generally the i o handling
involves taking input from some external
source it can be the command line it can
be from a file it can be from another
consumer application it can be from a
hard disk but the basic idea is that
whenever you have to do that input
output handoff or input output operation
we call that as i o generally whenever
you will hear the term i o we refer to
the input output operations with respect
to the file system or the hard disks or
the external disks basically now when we
talk about streams what is an io stream
so the basic idea is that you have an
input source you have an output
destination now the way that the input
source sends the data to the destination
is via streams so basically it converts
the data into one and zero and that one
and zero travels as a stream for example
you can see this pretty good image here
where you have a data source and you
have a program and your program is
trying to read the data from this data
source which is basically sitting on the
file system and this data gets converted
into zeros and once and then this is
streamed to the program bit by bit or
piece by piece similarly when the
program wants to send the data back to
the data source it again goes in the
form of stream so when we talk about
stream we also use the terms as input
stream or output stream so a program
uses an input stream to read data from a
source remember whenever we are reading
we will call it as input stream and
whenever we are writing something we
will call that as output stream remember
that because i will be using this for
these particular terms again and again
in the demo so that's the basic idea
about streams that you convert this into
one and zero and input stream means
reading something and output stream
means writing something so now that we
have built that understanding let's have
a look at what kind of classes support
java provides to do this iu streaming
operations so this is the java io
hierarchy where you have the object
super class and then you have different
types of streams stream classes so you
have input stream you have output stream
you have reader and you have writer so
if you talk about this particular
section in the input stream you have a
file input stream in the output stream
you have a file output stream this is
basically showing an inheritance
relationship so you have the input
streams for reading something you have
the output stream for writing something
and you have java provides the classes
to write to read from a file or to write
to a file using the file input stream
and the file output stream class
respectively there are more classes
under it but only a few are few of them
are shown for simplicity similarly if i
go to the right side i also have a
reader class and a writer class which
also have an input stream reader and
output stream reader and again these
have multiple other sub classes like
file reader buffer reader and file
writer so i will also try to showcase
the understanding of why we need this
and why we need these i mean ultimately
you have to write a stream right so why
creating two different types of classes
i will come back to that in a while with
that understanding let's go into looking
at an example and let's build an
understanding of how do we work with
streams and this is also the session
where i will talk about the file
handling operations in detail
so to understand that
i have created two different examples
one for byte stream and one for
character stream so let's take that
concept first why do you need two
different types of streams and the
reason is pretty simple whenever you are
reading data from some some data source
or writing data to the data source so
the data can either be simple character
strings like english characters or the
unicode characters or it can be some
tabular data setting in a table in a
database it can be an xml file it can be
an html file it can be literally
anything it can be a mathematical
expression file it can be an image you
don't know that so that's the reason
java created two different types of
classes that if you want to
work on
a particular file which is holding
characters then you can use character
stream and if you are dealing if you
don't know what kind of data the file is
going to contain then just use byte
streams character streams also
internally will be using the byte stream
only but it is much more simpler and
much more faster to use character
streams if you just have character files
also it is worth noting that when you
are using character stream the file will
be read character by character and when
you are using byte stream the file will
be read bite by byte so one byte at a
time and one character at a time so
let's look at the byte stream example
first i've created a class called byte
stream example it has a public static
void bin method and then i'm using the
file input stream and file output stream
classes basically what i'm trying to do
in this example is i'm trying to read a
file and write to a file and like i said
the uh when we look at the theory
whenever we are using the input stream
term we are primarily doing a read
operation and whenever we are using the
output stream term we are writing
something to the file so for these kind
of operations java provides for file
handling java provides these two classes
which are called file input and file
output stream so i create null
references and then i enter a try block
and inside the try block i basically
provide a location to read the file from
so i've created a source.txt
in the java tutorials location and if i
show you what this source file is
containing so if i go to this location
java tutorials and if i open the source
file it just has a simple text which
says this is a sample text file let me
delete this dest.txt for now so i just
have a source.txt here which is
containing a sample text this is a
sample text file so i am reading the
source.txt using the file input stream
and storing the output into this in
stream which is a byte stream and i'm
also creating another output stream
where i will be writing the destination
file so i'm saying this particular
location write the file with the name
test.txt but these are still just
containers i haven't done much here so
you are going to initialize the reading
stream and the writing stream and then
you are going to read one byte at a time
till the time you reach the end of the
file the way to denote the end of the
file or the way java tells you that you
have reached the end of the file is when
the read operation returns -1 so you
keep reading the file till the read
operation returns the value as minus one
whenever it returns the value as minus
one it means that you have reached the
end of the file so i'm going to read
this source.txt byte by byte one byte at
a time till my
until i reach the end of the file so i
call in stream dot read i store the
output of in stream dot read into a
variable called content and at the same
time i also run this condition that till
the time this output is not equal to -1
keep writing right where right to the
outstream so i want to write to this
particular stream so i i call the write
method and remember this is a byte
stream but here i the output of in
stream dot read was an integer output so
you need to convert this int output to a
byte by doing the explicit casting here
so we do the explicit casting here so
that the int con content gets converted
into a byte type and then outstream dot
write writes that byte inside the stream
onto this particular file so that's what
is happening here that you load the in
stream you read the file byte by byte
and you start writing the
output file byte by byte that's what you
do in this while loop once you have
reached the end of the file you will be
broken out of the while loop because the
whole file has been read and whatever
was written in that file has been
written to the outstream to this
particular file location and then in the
finally block you close both of the
streams remember it's very important to
close these resources otherwise these
resources will be present till the time
java runs a garbage collection so it's
very important to make sure that you
close all the resources which you open
in terms of file handling these are
costly connections and they take up lot
of memory so make sure that you close
them in the finally block and that's why
if you see i don't have a catch block
here but i've put the final block so
that i can say i can seamlessly close
them so that is what i'm doing here and
now if i run this i don't get any output
because i'm not printing anything but if
i go to this particular location and see
if i have a desk.txt so yes our desk.txt
has just appeared which was not there
earlier and if i double click on this it
has the exact same text
as i had in my source.txt so the
source.txt and the desk.txt have the
same content because i've just written
the source.txt to the desktop c dest.txt
so this is how you can use byte stream
operations to do file handling now let's
have a look at the character stream
example it is doing exactly the same
thing it's just that you have to use
different classes so instead of file
input stream and file output stream we
are going to use file reader and file
writer so i create the file leader and
file add references let's call it as
reader for simplicity
and let's call this as
writer so i initialize file reader and
file writer again pointing to the same
location let me delete the desktop txt
again so that we can observe the output
so i create the object for file writer
and file reader and i again do the same
thing i call the read operation the read
operation is going to return an integer
value output and i am going to continue
reading the file character by character
this time the byte is not read but the
actual character of the file is being
read so i'm going to read this file
character by character till i reach the
end of the file which is denoted by this
condition and as the output is end i
need to convert this into care so i cast
the int output to a care output and then
write it to the writer then i close the
reader and writer both and that's it so
if i run this now and if i go back here
i will see desk.txt and i see the output
here exactly as same so in terms of
output there was no difference but since
this was a purely character file the
character stream demo is a better use
case or like file reader and file later
classes are a better use case but like i
said there would be cases where you have
to read it as bytes because for example
if you're dealing with databases or if
you're dealing with another type of
files for example image files etc that
will be traveling as bytes so using a
byte stream might be a better example in
that case and that's that holds true for
any other different type of data source
as well let's get started with using
jdbc in java to connect to the databases
in this example i'm using the open
source community edition postgresql but
you can use any database vendor provider
if you want to if you want to use oracle
or mysql feel free to do that but in
this demo i'm going to use postgres so
you can download the postgres windows
installer since am using a windows
machine here you can download the
installer from the official
postgresql.org website and you can also
download the jdbc driver for post resql
going to this particular official
website which is jdbc
jdbc.postgresql.org
similarly you will be able to find the
jdbc driver for all other database
vendor providers as well once you
download this this is going to download
a jar for you and you can store the jar
anywhere like i put this jar into this
particular location you can see this
latest jdbc driver jar for post sql so
for every database vendor there would be
a different jdbc jar which you need to
download so that's that you install the
postgresql you set up its database and
when you install the postsql you also
get a nice sql client to talk to the
database because database has a server
and database has a client right so to
deal with that you install the server
and all these database vendors like
postgres oracle microsoft sql etc they
also provide a nice thin client with it
postgres also provides a client when you
install the
postgres server it will also ask you or
it will actually automatically install
the sql client for it as well which is
called pg admin so this is how the pg
admin client looks like the current
edition of it is pg admin 4 so you will
get that installed automatically and
once your postgres server has been
successfully installed if you just go to
search and type pg admin you will get
this option once you click on this
option a new browser window will be
opened and you will see this client here
you will not see this particular window
let me let me close this one but you
will see something like this you will
see a server here so you can go inside
it you will see a postgresql edition
here and if you go inside it you will
see a database here if you open the
database you will see the postgres
database by default created so you can
just right click on this and create a
database here you can name it as
whatever you want you can leave
everything as is for now and hit save
another thing which you need to do when
you do the installation is it will ask
you to set a database user and password
so choose whatever database username and
password you are comfortable with and
you will be using that user username and
password in your program as well so
create your database here and just leave
the database at this particular point
and now we will try to connect to this
particular database in the in the
example which i prepared i'm going to
connect to this test database so let's
go to the jdbc demo and see what is
happening there so for this purpose i've
created a class called jdbc demo it has
a public static void main method and
there's a lot going on here so let's
take it step by step and i will be keep
shuffling between the database sql
client and this particular class to
build a nice narrative so if you think
carefully what you need to have if you
want to connect to a database the
obvious answer is the address of the
database where is the database you need
to know the location of the database to
connect to it so that is called the
connection url every database vendor
will provide its own connection url and
you can find that connection url from
the official documentation there are
tons of examples available for it as
well but always refer to the official
documentation for that particular
database provider the general syntax is
jdbc colon your database vendor's name
colon double slash the host name this
can be any ip address or your local host
generally we also put a port here
something like this 5432 is the port on
which the post resql server runs but
again you can put the post the port here
on which your database server is running
every database vendor has their own
default port the postgres sql server has
the default port as 5432 so you provide
the hostname you provide the port and
then you provide the database name you
provide the database name to connect to
so if you remember i told you that i
have written the program to connect to
this particular database called test so
whatever that be you provide that name
here and this is going to form the
connection url i can remove this for now
but this is how the connection string is
going to look like and it is going to
its follow it follows the same format
for any database vendor that you say
jdbc column you write the database
vendor name and then you say column
double slash you provide the host port
and then you provide the database name
so that is your connection url after
that to connect to uh connect your java
program to a database you need to use
the
java.sql.connection class this is very
critical class and very important and
probably the single most important class
which you need to have in your program
if you want to connect to a database
so you say connection con equal to null
i'm just creating a null reference to it
and before we go any further let me also
tell you why we need this jdbc and what
is actually this jdbc so
java is a programming language it does
not comes with its own database but
there are multiple other vendors like
postgresql mysql microsoft sql oracle
etc so java wanted to provide a uniform
way to connect to all of these databases
because imagine all of these databases
building their own api contract it would
have been a nightmare for the developers
to connect to different databases or
shift from one database to other
database and that's the reason java
created this nice interface called jdbc
and it said whoever wants to connect to
java should follow this jdbc
specification and provide their
implementation similar to the the
interface and concrete class thing it's
not exactly that but you can think of it
in that manner that jdbc provides an
interface with the method declarations
and then oracle postgresql mysql all
these database vendors are supposed to
implement that interface and provide
their own implementation but jdbc apis
will always remain the same whoever
wants to connect to java has to create a
driver and that driver contains that
implementation and that's the reason we
downloaded that jdbc driver and i will
come to how how do we include that but
that's the background of jdbc and that's
why you need jdbc to build that uniform
contract and your vendor will provide
their own jar which will have the
implementation of the jdbc interface and
in this program what i'm trying to do is
basically i'm trying to insert a record
into a table so what is a table and how
do you create that so let's go back here
so in this test database
you will see a schema by default you
will see a public schema and you can
create a new schema if you want to or
you can just use the public schema so
inside the public schema you will go
under and you will see a an entry for
tables so you just right click and you
say create table you can also write in
complete sql statement but i'm just
showing you how to do that in pg admin
and you can give the table name you can
give the column information and that's
how you create the table so i have
created a table here which is called
student and the student table has three
columns roll number name and page if i
show you the exact query or the whole
create tdl for it it looks like this so
i created the
student table in the public schema which
has a roll number field a roll number
column which is of type numeric it has a
name column which is a varchar or a
character varying and it has a age
column which is again a numeric so roll
number name and age these are the three
different columns which i created inside
the student table so i have a student
table with these three columns so that's
that now let's go back to the program so
i have the student table and now i want
to insert some records in the student
table so let me just change the values
here so that we can see a different
entry so i have just hard-coded some
values generally you will be getting
these values from somewhere in the
program but for simplicity let's say you
have got those values once you've got
those values the next thing you need to
do is to build the sql statement the
exact sql statement which the postgres
which is going to be run on the post sql
server so you write that statement in
this case i'm showing you in a creation
example so it is going to be an insert
query so i say insert into table name
which is student and then i provide all
the column names it is always a better
practice to provide the column names in
these brackets even if you're inserting
the values to all the columns still
provide the column names so i say insert
into table column values and then you
provide the actual values as the roll
number variable which i created here the
name variable and the age variable
values so i just supply the values here
remember the when you are inserting the
values roll number and age are integer
so you don't need to put any single
commas single inverted commas for it but
name is a string variable so i put this
single inverted commas it's a simple
string concatenation nothing fancy here
so i'm just writing and a plain sql
statement here and storing that into a
string once i've done that the next
piece which i need to do is to get a
connection to the database and the way
you are going to get a connection is by
this uniform method no matter which
database provider you are using you are
always going to use the
drivermanager.getconnection method to
get a connection to the database and how
do you get the connection you supply the
connection url you supply the username
to connect to the database and you
supply the password in this case i've
just set the username and password as
postgres and postgres so postgres is the
username and postgres is the password
pretty lame i accept but this is just
for demonstration purpose so it's fine
but generally you will be getting these
values from some application property
file so these are the three parameters
which you need to supply to this get
connection method and then you will get
a live connection to the database this
is this this is the line which is going
to make it all happen to connect to your
database server so if this line gets
executed successfully you have a live
connection once you have a live
connection the next thing which you are
going to do is to create a statement
object on the connection statement is it
can be anything it can be an insert
statement or a select statement or
update statement or a delete statement
everything is a statement there right so
that's why you need to create a
statement object so you create a
statement object and then you execute
the sql this insert sql which you
prepared you're going to execute the sql
here saying st dot execute update
execute update is the method which is
used for any insertion or deletion
operations so that's the method you're
going to use and supplying the sql query
which you built with the actual values
of roll number name and age the execute
update method returns the number of rows
affected once this statement got run on
the database server or the sql query got
run on the database server it might
impact one rows if it's just if it's an
insertion it might impact multiple rows
if it was an update query right so it is
going to return the number of rows
affected and that is what we are going
to use to check if my insertion
successfully went or my insertion failed
so if this execute update is going to
return 1 which means that my row got
inserted successfully in the database so
i'm just printing us this out here and
if any if this particular m returned 0
which means none of the rows were
affected by my sql query which means my
insertion operation failed so i'm just
printing assist out here and then i'm
just putting this in a catch block here
to print any error and finally closing
the connection this is again very very
important database connection is one of
the costliest connections you will be
creating when you will be writing your
java applications always and always make
sure to close this database connections
otherwise your application is going to
face serious database bottlenecks so we
close the connection so that's all we
are doing here we prepare the url we
prepare we just create a placeholder for
connection object we prepare our scale
query with all the relevant values we
get a connection to the database we get
a create statement we get a statement
object from the create statement method
and then we execute the statement and
then we can validate the statement
execution if there is a way to validate
it once you've done all of that you
close the connection so let's run this
program and see if we can see this new
record inside the student table and
before we do that let's also validate
what is present in the student table as
of now so if i go here and i say view
all rows this is just going to run a
select star on the student table so
currently student table has one record
with role number one name as john and
age as 20 and now i am trying to insert
another row with roll number two name as
jane and age as 22. so if i right click
and run as java application i get this
entry which says inserted successfully
which is coming from here insert it
successfully and it also prints the
exact sql so that you can see what sql
actually got executed on the database
server this is the same string sql which
i built so this is the sql which got run
on the server which said insert into
student values and the role number the
role number was 2 and the name was jane
with single inverted commas because this
was a string and then age was 22. this
was the exact sql which got executed so
my sql has been executed my connection
has been closed if i go back to the pg
admin client and if i try to rerun this
query now i get two records so if you
remember this record was already there
but now i get the second entry which is
the new entry it just got inserted
because i did i ran the program and you
see the roll number two the name as jane
and the age as 22. so this was a very
simple example to show you how you can
do the jdbc correction but one of the
things which i still haven't covered is
the usage of the jdbc driver the jar
which i talked about so the way you are
going to add the jar is you go to the
project you right click on the project
you go to the build path go to the
configure build path and there you will
see different tabs source projects
libraries so go to the libraries tab and
select the class path here and you can
choose the add external jars option
click on this load your
jdbc jar for your particular database
vendor for my case it was post resql let
me just quickly remove this jar and show
you right from how it's done so this is
how it will look like for you you select
the class path you click on add external
jars you go to the location where you
have downloaded your jdbc driver jar for
your particular database select that
click open it will come here hit apply
and close that's how the jar is going to
be there if you don't provide the jar
your program is going to fail miserably
it is not going to work so make sure
that you have the jar and then only it
is going to be able to create a
successful connection and be able to
successfully execute the query remember
jdbc provides the specifications and
then the particular database vendor like
postgresql provides the jdbc driver
which has the implementation for that
jdbc api and that the java has this
uniform jdbc avi api and every database
vendor is expected to honor and
implement that api only so that java
developers can work on the jdbc contract
and everything should work as is let's
get started with generics in java so
before we go about generics let's
understand why do we need generics and
what what was the requirement that led
to the creation of generics so as we
know that when we work in any object
oriented programming language we created
classes we create objects we create
variables and everything has a type
everything has a type and the type is
static the type cannot be changed that's
why we call java as
a strong type checking language at
compile time it checks the types of the
variables of the classes at the compile
time and if the classes are mismatching
or their types are mismatching then you
basically get a compilation error but
what we see as we as we moved along we
saw that we were creating the similar
kind of functionality again and again in
different classes for example if there
is a login functionality which should
allow a person to log in and we should
also allow an application to log in then
these are the two different use cases
but the functionality still remains the
same so how would the login
functionality allow both of the types of
entities be it user or application to
get into the application or login into
the consumer application how do you do
that and that's what led to the creation
of generics that you can reuse the same
code with different types of inputs
remember the stress here is on the types
and that's what it is mentioned here
that we will like to reuse the same code
with different inputs we will just keep
changing the type parameters and we'll
keep using the same same code again and
again it has some benefits over the
non-generic code like we mentioned like
i mentioned earlier that when we work
with the non-generic code we have the
statically assigned types to the
variables and objects and if we use
generics then we don't have to do that
and at the same time you don't even have
to explicitly cast them we touched upon
this concept of
generics in different bits and pieces in
different sessions throughout this
tutorial series where we saw that
whenever i was creating a list i was
supplying this type into these brackets
right and i told that this that this is
the generic type but now we'll go deeper
into this concept and we'll see how we
can create our own generic types if java
does not provide it so with that let's
move to an example and see how we can
implement our own generic types to
create generic code
where we can supply the types
dynamically so i've prepared an example
for this i've actually prepared two
examples for this and we'll go through
both of them one by one so here what i'm
doing that i'm creating any class you
can think of it as any class holding any
functionality which is applicable to
multiple entity types think of it as the
same login class which i just talked
about so if your class has a
functionality which should be reused by
many different types then one of the way
to not repeat the code or repeat the
class or repeat the functionality again
and again is to make that class use a
generic signature and how you do that
you write the class name and then you
put these brackets and you just type t
you can write any variable abc or
whatever you feel like but t is sort of
the
default standard the java developers
have been using since generics was
launched so you put this t here now
whoever calls this class or whoever
whoever initializes this class will have
to supply the type of the class on which
this particular functionality is going
to get executed now remember the
collection examples i took i took in the
past series what if this was a list
class because we have used the exact
same syntax right we use list we put
brackets and then we wrote string and we
said okay now this list is a
list of strings if we said list of
integer then we just write integer in
these brackets and that list became a
list of integers so you see the same
list was being reused for different data
types and the exact same concept is
applied here for your custom classes and
your on your own custom functionality so
i write t here then i can do whatever
with this t i want so i just
put a reference of it inside the class i
create a constructor constructor is also
assigning the t type i do a get object
and that's all it's a very simple toy
example but just to get the point across
you can write as complex logic as you
want inside the class depending upon
your use case but this is just a
straightforward example that you can use
generics in the classes as well once you
do that then how do you initialize this
class
so let's have a look at that as well so
i've just created a public static void
bin method inside the same class
obviously you can create this method
outside the outside this class as well
there's no stopping that logic but but
for the sake of simplicity i just put
the main class here so it's a simple
public static void main method there i
am initializing the single generic
holder class the same class and here the
t type is of integer this t type can be
of anything else as well for example
your own student class can also be
supplied here and then the single
generic holder will become of student
type in this case i'm just using a
pre-built java class so this single
generic holder becomes of integer type i
give a reference i create an object
and i provide a value to the object
because you see the constructor is this
whatever t you supply so if the t is the
integer this t becomes integer and this
obj is going to hold the value 10
because that's the constructor being
called here and after that you can do
whatever you want in terms of the logic
here i'm just i've just have i just have
a get object method so i'm just calling
that method and printing the object
that's all similarly you can also
initialize the same class with the
string type so you see i'm reusing the
same class in the same functionality
again and again for different class
types so this time i'm using the string
type instead of integer and i'm
supplying a string parameter this time
and this this constructor still will
work because this is generic when you
created with integer this constructor
this t became of integer type and when
you initialize it with the string type
this constructor started accepting the
string objects so just supply a string
called simply code and then i call get
object
so let's run this method so when we run
the main method from the first
invocation at line 16 and 17 when you
call the get object the value of the
object gets printed which is 10 for the
integer and then at line 20 the value of
the string gets printed which is simply
code so that's how you can use generics
inside a class or for a class now there
might be use cases where you have to
create a class which can accept multiple
types of generic types let's take an
example if you remember when we talked
about hash map we had the exact same
situation so you had the key and you had
the value now key can be of any type any
data type it can be string integer
whatever and then value can also be of
any data type it can also be your custom
data types for example the key becomes a
roll numbers and the value becomes
student object so map is a situation
where you have two generic types so i'm
just trying to replicate that similar
kind of behavior that if you have to
create a class with two three as many
generic types as you want you can still
do that by just providing a comma here
you can go on doing as many generics as
you want in this example i'm using two
generics and then it again goes to the
same drill that i've created references
for both d and u i have initialized both
p and u in the constructor and then i
have a display method which is going to
call the and display the obj-1 and obj
2's values or there are two string
methods basically because when you when
you try to call the object inside the
system.out.println method the by default
the tostring method of the object will
automatically get called so that's all i
have in this particular class so i it's
a simple class accepting two different
types of generics and then calling the
display method and here is the public
static void main method for the same
here i am initializing the dual generic
class and here the t is string and u is
integer so these t and u are
assigned these class types and then i
create the class i again write the same
types and i provide the value so for the
string one i provide simply code for the
integer 1 i provide 10 this constructor
gets called obj 1 gets the value simply
code and obj 2 gets the value 10 and
then i call display method there i am
printing obj 1 and obj 2. so let's run
this method okay i'm getting simply code
in 10 because when i call the display
method at line 13 obj 1 gets printed obj
1 is holding simply code value and at
line 14 obj 2 gets printed or the two
string method of the obj2 gets printed
which is holding the value 10. so this
was a quick tour to tell you how can you
use generics you can obviously use
generics in the variable types as well
you can use generics in the method
argument types as well wherever you want
the simple idea is that one you would
like to reuse the functionality again
and again and second you would like to
you would not like to have a strong
strict type checking and like i said try
to relate these generic concepts with
the collection framework we listen
because correction framework is
completely built upon the concept of
generics whenever we initialize a list
or a map or a hash set or a linked list
or error list or anything we always
supply the type and that type is coming
from these uh if you look at the
implementation of error list class you
will see that let me see if i can open
that for you to show you how that looks
like if i go to an example of
collections and if i try to just open
the class you will be able to see that
yep so if i click on this list class you
see list of e type so here e is the type
which you are going to supply so in this
particular case when you say list of
integer this integer gets
typed into e so whatever so this this
whole list class whatever operations you
are doing inside the list class will be
applied for the integer type so
similarly you can look at other
collection classes and you will always
see these generics everywhere in the
collection classes let's get started
with string handling in java so we have
been dealing with string types
throughout different sessions in this
whole series but in this session we are
going to look at lot of different
utility methods which the string class
provides string class is very versatile
in java and it provides lot of handy
functions which can help you manipulate
strings in multiple ways for example if
you want to trim a string or if you want
to append a string to another string or
if you want to find a particular
character at a particular index or if
you have an index and you want to see
what character is present at that
particular index or if you want to do
any other kind of pattern matching in
the string so string is very versatile
in that in that context and today we
will have a look at some of those
methods so i've just opened the java
docs api for string and you can see in
the method summary you will find a long
list of methods we will go through some
of these methods for example if i just
show you a snapshot of what i'm talking
about it has a care act method so you
provide a index and integer index and
this particular method will tell you
which character is present at that
particular index in the string remember
string is basically a zero based
character array zero index based
character array similarly you can also
call code point at which is going to
return the character in the unicode code
point at a specified index similarly
compared to method can be used to
compare two strings with each other
compared to ignore cases also there
which can compare two strings ignoring
whether they are in uppercase or
lowercase you can use concat method to
join two strings together you can use
the contains method to find if a
particular character or a particular
sequence of character exists in a
particular
string or not you can do a content
matching you can do copy you can also
see if a particular string ends with a
particular character or a sequence of
characters so there are tons of
different methods available here and
please do check out the api because like
i said this is going to come very handy
when you start writing real time
projects or the real life projects so
with that knowledge let's go to uh our
ide and let's have a look at some of
these examples in action so here also
you can obviously have a look at the
string class uh
from the ide itself just write string
and hit control and you will see an
underline and a hyperlink so just click
on this and you in the string class will
be opened and you can actually read on
about the documentation of the whole
string class but we are not going to do
that we are going to have a look at some
real life examples of how we can use
different methods of the string class so
here i have created two strings str1 and
str2 str1 is holding a string which says
john is studying and str2 is holding a
string which says in college now the
first utility function which i'm going
to talk about is the length method so if
you want to find out what is the length
of this particular string then you can
just call the length method on the
string and that is going to return the
length of the current string let's see
that in action let me comment the rest
of the code and let's see this one in
action so if i run this program i get
the value 16. so if you count this 1 2 3
4 space is also counted 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16. so you get the exact
length of the string when you call the
length method similarly another method
is concat method and concat method is
used to concatenate two strings together
concatenation basically means joining
two strings together so if you want to
join the string one and string two then
just call str1 dot concat with the
string you want to append or you want to
concat so the concat method on the left
heights left hand side of the string is
going to get concatenated with the
argument which you pass in the concat
method so let's see that in action now
and let's see the result as well because
i'm storing the result of concatenation
into a new variable and printing that
variable so i get this whole text here
and you see the studying in just got
merged there was no space in between
because there is no space here if you
just put it like this and if you rerun
this you will see the proper space as
well while concatenation one of the
things which i also want to call out is
strings are immutable in nature when i
say immutable it it means that once you
have created this str1 holding this
value then st and then this particular
object's value pointing to str1 cannot
be changed you cannot mutate the strings
if you try changing str's value java is
going to create a new object and point
str1 to that object but the object which
was created initially is not going to be
overwritten so remember that concept
that whenever you're doing manipulations
on the string the previous string object
still remains there it doesn't get
overwritten or it doesn't get modified
whenever you modify a string you get a
new object that's the property of string
so we saw the concatenation let's move
ahead this also format method format
method is used to dynamically populate
some parts of the string for example if
you have a long list of students and if
you want to print the name of students
then what you can do here is that you
can change you can assign those names to
certain variables and you can point or
refer those variables in the string with
the percentage syntax percentage s
syntax basically so the string.format
method is used to supply dynamic values
inside a static string so in this case
this part of the string is static where
i'm saying the name of the student is
then in the next string remember plus
also can concatenate it it is also doing
the exact same thing as the concat
method okay it's just a shorthand so i'm
creating first string then i'm creating
second string but here i'm writing
percentage s i will come to that and
then i've created one more string where
i'm using percentage b so what happens
that java format method supports certain
special type of references for example
if you want to dynamically place a
string you can use percentage s if you
want to dynamically place an integer
value you can write percentage d in the
format method similarly you can also
write other percentage f for for a float
value and there are more other similar
placeholders which are available in the
format method so do check out the format
method documentation if you want to know
what all percentage types or variable
types can be dynamically placed inside
the format method here i'm just using
percentage s and percentage d and then
once you have created the first part of
the format method which is string with
with dynamic placeholders till this
particular point then you put a comma
and you start providing the values
remember the sequence of the values have
to be exactly the same way in which you
have used them here so if percentage s
is coming first then you have to supply
a string value if percentage d is coming
after that after the string value you
have to provide an integer value if
there was another percentage s after
percentage d in the same string then
after 21 you had to provide another
string value so that's the
contract which format method needs to
honor and if i run this particular
program and if i say if i try to see the
output let's try to see the output as
well and for the output i need to store
this whole string.formats output into a
variable so let's say i say string
r and then i can print r and see what
comes out so that's it let's run the
program now and now you will see this
line the name of the student is john
comma and the age is variable is 21 i
think it's coming because i've just
wrote variable is here but if you if you
remove this and if you say the age is
percentage d then you'll get a nice
human readable output without any extra
formatting so the name of the student is
john and the age is 21 and that there
was a comma that's why you still see the
comma but this is the basic idea with
using the format method now another
method which i want to talk about is a
cad at method let me comment the
previous output so that we can follow
along so i'm just going to comment all
of this which we have covered already
and let's focus on the care at method so
care at method can be used to find the
character present at a particular index
in a string so whatever index you
specify in the caret method the
character present at that particular
index will be returned so when i say
str1 dot care at 5 remember strings are
0 based indexed character arrays so
0 1 2 3 4 5 at 5 i is present so this
car at method should return i so if i
run this particular program yes i see
the output as i now let's move ahead uh
with next example or the next api call
the next api call is that usage of
equals method where i can see if the two
strings are equal or not so here i'm
saying str1.equals str2 if both strings
are same it is going to return true
otherwise it is going to return false so
if i run this i get the output as both
strings are different it goes in the
else block because str1 and str2 are
different they are holding different
values so here the exact content of the
string is going to be matched the next
one is the index of method so index of
method can be used just for the reverse
functionality of care at in carat we
were supplying the index and getting the
character here we can supply the
character and get the index of it so
what what is going to happen that you
write the string dot index off and then
you supply the character where which for
which you want to find the index of so i
supply y here and if i run this
particular program for this line the
output is 12. let's see if the output is
correct so here if you try to find what
is sitting at the index number 12 in
this string so again 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12. so yes y is present at
the 12th index and that's the output i
get what if you provide a character
which is not present in this particular
string that says z which is not there
and see what the output is in that case
you will get the output as minus one so
if the character is not present in the
string you will get the output as -1
another thing what if the
character is
present more than once in the string for
example i is present more than one time
in the string so if i write i here
whether i get the index of this i or
this i let's see so i'm going to run
this program again and i get the value 5
so 5 is basically this i because this is
definitely not 5 it's far
far further index so the first match of
the index is going to be returned in
terms of the index of method okay so
that was about the index of let's look
at the next one which is the replace in
replace it's as the name suggests you
can replace a character or a sequence of
characters in a string by calling the
replace method on the string on which
you want to do the manipulation and
remember you're doing the manipulation
here so the previous object is not going
to get overwritten but a new object is
going to get created so what i want to
replace is with r so in this particular
string i see an occurrence of s here so
this s should be replaced with r if the
replace functionality works as i just
explained so let's run this program and
yes i can say instead of s i c are being
replaced there and that's the usage of
the replace method next one is the split
method where if you want to split the
string into multiple elements so you
just call the split method and you
provide the separator here i'm
separating the string whenever there is
a space i'm basically breaking up the
string into multiple sub strings that's
what i'm doing here or multiple strings
i would just call it as so whatever
separator you provide whenever the
string is going to encounter that
separator it is going to split one part
of it so in on providing the separator
as space it means in this particular
case i'm going to get three items the
first break up is going to go going to
happen here so the john part of it will
go out and this will go out in a
separate string then again between is
and studying i have another space so
there will be another break here so i
should get three elements if i call the
split method one element will be holding
the value john the second element will
be holding the value is and the third
element will be holding the value as
studying and then i'm printing all the
elements of the of the array remember
that split method returns a string array
so that's what i'm using here to store
the output of the split method and then
i'm just using the streams api to
iterate over this string array
outputting or printing the each element
of the array so let's run this program
okay so i can see three different
outputs through this
system.out.println first john then is
then starting like i said split method
is going to create a three element size
array of strings because i'm separating
it based on the space the last utility
function which i want to talk about so
this is the last one but i'm skipping
some of some more due to the interest of
the time but like i said do check out
the documentation to read or understand
more about other string utility methods
which i'm not covering here in this
session so the last one i'm going to
talk about is the substring method and
substring is basically going to take a
mini string out of the long string so
what if you want to trim the string what
if you have a long string and you only
want to get a part of the string so you
can specify the starting point we can
specifying the you can specify the end
point and whatever string characters are
present between the starting index and
the end index will be taken out from the
string and you can store that output
into a new string and print that so here
i'm calling the substring method
providing the starting index as one and
the ending index is five let's run this
program and interpret the output so i'm
getting the output as o h n so what is
happening here let's go back to the str1
so i said start with one remember string
is a zero based index so it starts with
zero one it starts with o because o is
present at the first index and then i'm
going up till five so one gets printed
whatever character is present at one
index get printed second index get
printed third index gets printed fourth
index gets printed which is just a space
and then the fifth index is i which is
not printed here so it means that when
you call the string substring method
then the end index position will not be
printed it starts from the beginning
index and it will go till index mine end
index minus one position in terms of
printing because if you select this
you'll see an extra bar here because the
space is also getting printed so it is
printing everything before the fifth
index it will not include the fifth
index character remember that when you
use the substring functionality that the
end index is not included in the
substring if you want to include that
you need to increase the index by one so
for example if you want to print i as
well then you have to write it as and
index s6 and if you run this then you
will also see i now yep so that is how
this uh substring functionality works
let's get started with java.lang package
so java.lang package is one of the most
core and fundamental packages in java
which is provided out of the box to the
developer you never explicitly import
this package in your java program
because you don't need to java provides
this automatically the moment you create
a file with dot java extension or and
you have you are running that particular
program inside or on a jdk you get the
java.lang package automatically for
example when we were when we were
running the string handling demo i was
using the string class but i never
imported the string class you can see
there is no import for string because
string class is also part of the
java.lang package it's automatically
imported for you you never need to
explicitly import the package or any
classes of that package so this is going
to be more of a theoretical lecture
where we will just have a look at our
quick overview of all the java.lang
package classes and other utilities you
don't need to remember all the classes
and utilities but this is just to give
you a sense of what all it contains
so in terms of the interfaces it has the
appendable interface autoclave auto
closable care sequence clonable
comparable if you remember we also used
comparable when we were writing the
comparable
implementation to compare different
objects in a collection so this also
comes automatically as part of the
java.lang package iterable runnable
again we use this in the in the
threading example so this also comes
automatically to you you never need to
import the renewable class from the
java.lang package when we move to the
classes all the data type classes which
you can think of in terms of boolean
byte character class class loader
compiler enums even float integer long
math so all the classes which we were
using the the data type classes which we
were using in different examples are
also part of the java.lang package okay
so this is a long list long list it also
has a thread class so whenever you are
creating thread you again never imported
thread class but it still just worked
fine because there was uh
this was also coming as part of the
java.lang package there are also bunch
of enumerations which it provides in
terms of unicode thread state etc it
also provides exception classes like
arithmetic exception or or the different
runtime exceptions which we dealt with
like array index out of bound array
store class cast class not supported the
root exception class so a lot of
exception classes also come as part of
the java.lang package it also provides
some error classes if you remember when
we talked about the exception framework
you have the error types and you have
the exception types so it also provides
some error classes if you want to use
that you don't you never need to import
any of these classes and you will
automatically get them from the
java.lang package similarly it also
provides some annotations as well like
functional interfaces or you remember we
use this annotation a lot the add the
rate override annotation but we never
imported the override class or the
override annotation because it's part of
the java.lang package so this basically
tells us that there are a lot of
different classes utilities enums errors
exceptions data types which are provided
out of the box from the java.lang
package which makes our life so much
easier whenever we want to work with
java because we don't need to import the
very basic classes which
which we use very frequently and another
very important package is the java.util
package we have been using the java.util
package in all of the collections
examples and tutorials we walk through
in this whole tutorial series so let me
just open the java.util package for you
so if i go here to java.util and
i will be able to see the java.util
packages different classes etc yes so
here is here it is the java.util package
and remember java.util package is not
imported automatically you have to
explicitly import the java.util package
to use the classes of it so it so that's
the difference between java.lang package
and java.util package that you cannot
you can use
the classes coming from the java.lang
package without explicitly importing
those classes or importing the java.lang
package but java.util package is
something which you have to explicitly
import in your java program to make it
work or even make it compile so what
java.util provides first of all the
collections framework the whole
collections framework comes from the
java.util package so for example all the
interfaces which we use while we work
with the collections framework classes
interfaces like collection list set map
you can see the map interface you can
see the list interface with the generics
so all the interfaces which we use from
in the collections framework are present
in the java.util package similarly when
we talk about the classes all the
concrete classes implementation of the
collections framework in terms of error
list linked list hash map hash set
preset tree map you will see all of
those classes here here we are covering
all the this is showing all the classes
summaries so you see some abstract
classes and you will also see some
concrete classes as you move further
down in this particular list so you see
hash map you see hash set hash table
linked map linked asset linked list we
used all of these classes while we were
going through the collections framework
tutorials so it provides all of these
and lot of other classes like the
scanner class which we covered in the
java project for taking the inputs from
the command line from the user
stack class again from the collection
some time classes and it also provides
bunch of enumerations like the locale
basically setting the language
categories for a particular program it
also provides some exceptions which we
used while we were working with the
collections framework so most of these
exceptions are or some of these
exceptions are related to the collection
classes for example the concurrent
modification exception gets thrown uh
whenever you your the whole execution
detects concurrent modification of an
object when such modification is not
allowed you will see other different
types of exceptions like illegal format
etc in this particular exception section
of this particular package then it also
provides just one error class as well so
this is what the java.util uh package
contains and just to refresh your memory
whenever we ran any collection demo we
always imported the java.ut classes you
can see this is all coming from
java.util so this is something which you
have to import without which your
program will not even compile so that's
also one of the difference between the
java.lang package and the java.util
package and that's pretty much all i
want to cover in this particular session
so
we basically did a quick tour of the
java.lang package and the java.util
package and like i said it's impossible
to cover all of that for all of the
classes and enums and interfaces and
errors and exceptions
with all the examples so i would suggest
you to just keep this in mind about the
java.lang package and java.util package
i told you the basic construct that
java.lang contains all the types the
class and the variable types or the data
types we dealt with and java.util
majorly contains all the collection
classes uh that's that's that's the
basic thing which you need to remember
whenever you work with java and your
java.lang package never needs to be
imported but java.util package needs to
be imported always whenever you use the
util classes let's get started with
networking in java so when we talk about
the networking in java java has a whole
dedicated package called java.net
package which has all the different
classes which you need to have to write
a networking program in java so we'll
you will see bunch of classes with two
classes most important ones which are
inet 4 address and inet 6 address so as
you can see you can understand that inet
4 address is the class which can be used
to represent the ipv4 addresses and inet
6 address class can be used to represent
ipv6 addresses and then you can learn
about sockets it also has socket classes
it has a lot of interfaces the with the
prominent one being the networking
interface there are some high level apis
for example the uri class is there which
can be used to represent a universal
resource identifier as specified in the
rfc and this is just an identifier this
doesn't provide the means to access the
resource if you want to access the
resource then you need to use url which
is the class representing the universal
resource locator which is a slightly
older concept than uri but with url you
can hold the address as well as access
the address url connection is also one
of the class which is created from the
url class to set up a communication link
with the url and similarly http url is
for an http connection and you have
protocol handlers there are a lot of
interesting classes which
you can explore if you want to learn
more about what all networking support
java provides but when we talk about the
basic ones like ipv4 address the url uri
classes these are the ones which
generally most developers interact with
you if you want to write a socket
programming
socket program that's used you can still
do that with the classes and interfaces
support provided by java so you can see
bunch of interfaces here cookie policy
socket option then in terms of classes
you can see again content handler cookie
manager http cookie i need four and i
need six address with the classes which
i talk about it also has a generic class
but i would always recommend to use one
of these if you know what address you're
dealing with uh the url connection the
jar url connection class proxy class
some bunch of socket classes uri url
classes and some enums and exceptions as
well which are related to networking
connections for example malformed url if
the url itself is is not correct then
you get a malformed url exception socket
exception if there's a socket timeout
exception then also you have a dedicated
exception for that so there are a bunch
of different exceptions classes enums
and interfaces available which you can
have a look at if you want to dig deeper
into it so i've also prepared a demo
where we will be using some of these
functionalities of these of this
particular package so let's jump to the
ide and see what i've built so here uh i
have created a class called networking
demo and what we are trying to do that
we will provide the simply launch url
and we will try to get bunch of
information about how this website is
hosted so you just create a simple
string variable and you can type any
string you can write
any favorite website of your choice here
and then we create the inet address
class and like i said you always use the
concrete implementation of the inet
address class which is in this case inet
4 address so i use the get by name and
we supply the url to get an inet address
object and what does inet address
contains it contains all the information
in terms of the internet address on
which that particular website is hosted
so you will see lot of different
functionality in this class let's
explore some of the functionality and
methods which are provided by the inet
address class so once you do this you
will get an inet address object if the
url is correct if the url is incorrect
you will get a malformed url exception
anyways if you want to just see the
address of
the ip address where this particular
website is hosted you can call the get
address method and if you want to see
the host address method then you can
call the get host address now you might
be wondering what is the difference
between get address and get host address
so let's get first that out let me
comment the rest of the code and let's
first focus on this particular part so
let me comment the local address part as
well we will come to that in a while and
i can just remove this comment so we are
printing the get address and the get
host address and let's see what values
do we get and how do we see if it's a
different value so this explains right
when we call init address dot get
address we just get all the values as we
know that when we deal with ipv4 address
the address has four values something
dot something dot something dot
something if you want to verify it just
go to your own laptop and you you will
be able to see some address like
192.168.something or something so that
so ip4iv4 address has four sections and
all the four sections will have some
values so if you use the get address
method and you try to convert this into
a string it basically will return an
array the get address method will return
an array which will look like this but
if you want to see it exactly in the
format in which the real world
networking protocols understand it then
use the get host address which is going
to show it exactly in the way in which
we write the ip address where we write
some integer dot some integer dot some
integer dot sum integer so that's the
difference between get address method
and get host address method same value
different representation the next
function which i'm going to talk about
is about local address and the local
address or the method name is is any
local address so this method is going to
tell me if there is a wildcard address
which is associated with this particular
host you can also see what this method
is doing from the documentation so if
you go to the documentation and if you
search for this particular method in the
inet 4 address class you will see it
says utility routine to check if the
inet address is a wild card address the
result will be a boolean which will
indicate if it has a wildcard address or
not so let's run this program and
understand if it has a wildcard address
no there is no wildcard address
associated for this particular website
similarly there is another method which
we can explore which is is link local
address so let's search for the
documentation of it first so this is the
class if you search it it will just show
you the exact class which is present
with the method and this method
provides basically a check to see if the
inet address is a link to a local
address within the domain of the website
so the result again will be a boolean if
it says true it means there is a link to
the local address and if it returns
false it means the address is not a link
local unicast address so let's see the
output of this in with respect to the
simply learned website so if i run this
program now i again get false so there
is no wildcard address attached or
associated with the website and it does
not point to a local unicast address
either is there a loopback mechanism now
these all are networking concepts and uh
since this is not a networking session
so i will not go deeper into what what a
loopback address
means in detail but to get to give you
an understanding of where it present and
how you can use this in java is what we
are going to focus on so if you want you
can always read about what is a loopback
address but if you want to know if the
url which you are pointing to is
the address which is returned by that
website has a loopback address or not
then you can use the is loopback address
method and this again returns true or
false based on whether it has a loopback
address or it does not have a loopback
address so if i run this particular
program we get the output false again so
no it the simplyland website does not
even also have a loopback address the
last one or the second last one which i
want to explore is the site local
address method so let's see what does
this method do let me just remove this
extra commented lines
so let's look at the documentation of
this method so this is a utility routine
to check if the init address is a site
local address the result is a boolean
indicating if the init address is a site
local address or false if the address is
not a cyclical site local unicast
address again this concept is again
a networking special concept for similar
to the loopback address so this is just
basically
showing if the site also has a uh
basically a local unicast address
associated with it or not so
if you want to see the site local
address output i have enabled that code
and if you run this particular program
we get false for that as well yes that
means that the the simple website is
built with pretty good practices there
is no loopback address there is no site
local address which we don't need for
for this particular website in this case
the last one is just a simple thing just
to see the hash code it's not much of a
relevance mostly the programs but just
to tell you that this is also available
so you can also see the hash code which
is
contained by the inet address object so
we covered bunch of functionality in
this particular example we had a look at
the java.net package it has an inet 4
address class and i net 6 address class
lot of networking exceptions and
interfaces support as well and the
simple way to use it is to you point it
to a website call the get by name call
the get host address and you will get
the ip address in the exact format in
which the networking world deals with it
similarly you can call the get address
to just get an array of it just as we
saw here and then there are a lot of
utility functions available in the inet
address class like is any local is link
local is loop back is site local and
there are actually more if you look at
this class you will find more methods
here in terms of what like for example
it also has a is multicast address this
is basically to check if the init
address is an ip multicast address so
there are a lot of different methods
here there are some mc methods as well
which will check which are specially
created for the multicast address
scenarios so a utility routine to check
if the multicast address has a global
scope if it has a local scope or sorry
it has a node scope basically or it has
a link scope or it has a side scope so
there are a lot of different methods
available for the multicast as well
which you can have a look at and we
already covered the get address the get
host address and the hash code address
classes there are some url classes as
well like i mentioned url ui classes are
also very important classes which you
might need to use whenever you are you
are building a connection with a
particular application based on their
url if you are doing socket programming
there are socket classes available which
you can also use while using the
networking concepts in java so you can
build a pretty decent and robust
application uh using the networking
classes and the networking support
provided by java to build a
networking application let's get started
with image handling in java so
we deal with images on a daily basis and
you will often be required to deal with
image handling in java programs as well
where you might need to re read an image
or write an image or load an image into
memory and do other kind of
manipulations on the images so java does
provide support for image handling as
well and uh
you can pretty much load up any type of
image be it a gif image or beta png or
beta jpeg image basically it converts
into a java 2d image to render it
and it basically creates a byte
representation of the image to serve and
save the contents so in this section we
are going to talk about the image
handling aspects of java and to do that
there are broadly two classes which java
provides as you can see in this official
documentation the first one is
java.awt.image class and the second one
is java.awt.image.bufferedimageclass
which extends the image class so this is
basically the super class as you can see
here which you can use to represent any
kind of graphical image as a 2d array of
pixels and buffered image is a concrete
implementation of the image class which
you can use to construct instances of
the class and buffered images is sort of
the i would say the de facto standard or
the go to class whenever you are dealing
with any kind of image rendering uh
tasks in a java program and we will also
have a look at how we can use the
buffered image class to basically read
and a sample image and also write a
sample image to a file system so
you can read more about this in the
documentation and
there are also bunch of documentations
available in terms of how you can read
it how you can load it into the program
how you can draw an image how you can
create and save the image etc and like i
mentioned we will be covering some
aspects of it in today's demo as well so
this was a very brief theoretical
introduction about image handling and
like i always mentioned if you want to
know more about this do check out the
official documentation of of java where
you can learn more about the image
handling classes and utilities so with
that let's move to the demonstration
part so i have prepared a demo here
which talks about image handling so i
have created a class called image
handling demo which has a public static
void main method and i'm just giving
some some sample uh dimensions for the
image in terms of width and height here
and then as i mentioned that we will be
using the buffered image class so i'm
creating an a reference for the buffered
image it's currently assigned to null so
basically is nothing and then i am
calling the method read from file so
like i mentioned you can you mostly will
be dealing with reading from an image or
writing to an image so here we will look
at both of the aspects as to how you can
load an image from your file system into
a java program and then write it back to
the file system from your java program
so let's first look at the read from
file method which will tell us how we
can read a java file so i provide some
sample dimensions these dimensions will
vary based on your use case and i supply
the buffered image object inside that i
have created a try block and in the try
block the first thing you need to do for
image handling is to basically create a
file object because image is also
technically just a file right so you
provide the file image path here at this
particular location so let's go to the
sample image part this is the
destination path and let me open the
sample image path as well which is
somewhere in the c drive so this is the
image which we are loading this is the
path which i have mentioned which is c
sample dot jpg so let's first have a
look at the image as well as to what
this image contains so this image is
basically from a from a clinical trial
and
showing some blood sample or some
vaccine bottles which is probably the
very uh popular image nowadays because
we are living in this pandemic world so
this is the sample image which i have
chosen to read and then i will load this
into the java program and then we'll try
to write it back to the file system to a
destination location so this is where my
image is present in the c drive named
with sample.jpg and this is what i've
supplied here so you just need to supply
it in double quotes remember when you're
dealing uh with windows file system you
always have to use double forward
slashes which is different if you're
working with a on a mac machine or
you're working on a linux system where
only
this will work fine so that's a bit
awkward thing which which windows has
and you have to respect the operating
systems restrictions or way of doing
things so once you have loaded the file
or created the uh
sample.jpg file object then the next
thing we are going to do is we are going
to create an object of the buffered
image remember we just created a
reference we did not create an object
yet of the buffered image class and now
is the time to do that so we supply the
width we supply the height and then we
supply the type of the image let's go to
the constructor of this image to see
what this image type means so this image
type can be basically the type of the
created image which comes from the color
space so whether it's an rgb image or a
rgb image or bgr image or byte gray
image there are multiple different types
of images in the media space and
whatever type of image you have you need
to basically supply that image type in
this particular argument so in my case
it was an argb image so i supplied that
particular if you click on this you will
see that currently it's inside java an
8-bit rgba image basically has a static
constant which is denoted by 2. you can
read more about this inside the buffered
image class documentation is as well so
once i've supplied that my buffered
image object is ready which has all the
details dimensions and the types of the
image now the next thing is that you
need to fill this image object with the
file so you basically need to read the
file and store the output of this read
operation into the buffered image object
then what will happen that along with
this information whatever is present
here will also be added to the same
buffered image object so to read a
image or simple a file java provides an
i o utility which is called image i o
and there is a read method available
which is a static method on this
particular class as you can see i'm
calling the class dot method name here
and then you supply the sample file name
once you have done that then it will
basically be reading the whole image
into a 2d byte array and copying that
over into this buffered image object
once that is done if this particular
line is successfully executed then you
will get this message which will say
reading complete and it will try to
print some hash code of the image object
and after that if there's any exception
in this block for example this
particular line may raise an exception
or this particular line may raise an
exception if the file does not exist
then you need to have the i o exception
caught remember i o is a checked
exception so if you are using these
operations file new file and
imageio.read you need to catch the i o
exception because it's a checked
exception so either you need to catch it
or you need to re-throw it these are the
only two options you have with the
checked exception so once we have done
all of that if everything goes fine if
everything is happy till line 35 then we
just return the image object and our
read from file operation will be done
going back to the main method once the
read operation is done the next thing
i'm going to do is writing this image
object to a new destination file so
let's see what is happening in this
write to file method because this is the
method which is responsible for writing
this image to a new destination location
so i've created a public static void
void method inside the same class where
the public static void main method is
present as you know that static methods
can only call other static methods
that's why this has this had to be
static and i'm supplying the same image
object which was returned from the read
operation that goes in as the argument
of this particular method and again i'm
using a file object and this time i'm
providing a destination location where i
would like to write this image so this
is the destination location i've chosen
which is f drive java tutorials folder
and the image should be stored with the
name out dot jpg so this is the location
there's already already an out.jpg here
so let me just remove it so that we can
observe the output so we create the file
object after that we again use the image
i o utility uh we call our static method
static utility method called write we
supply the whole image object we supply
the image type extension and we supply
the output location again if i take you
to the signature of this you take the
rendered image you take the format name
which is jpg and the output location so
these are the three things which you
need to supply
once you call the right method on the
image io utility class image io is a
very handy class and do remember this
class whenever you are dealing with uh
the image handling operations it will
provide lot of static convenience
methods so we write this file uh write
this image object to a file to a
destination location and if everything
goes fine in these two lines we will get
this message which will say writing
complete if anything goes wrong we again
catch the i exception and the exception
will be printed here that's all is
happening in this particular program
where we are reading from file and we
are writing to the file reading it from
here and writing it on this particular
location so let's run this program and
see if we are able to read from file
successfully and also write it to the
specified location so run as java
application it's a slightly memory heavy
operation so it takes a bit of time
because the whole image needs to be
loaded into memory be very careful about
that it might eat up your large portion
of your ram if the image is too heavy so
here it says reading complete and then
it prints the hash code details of this
particular object and then it also
executed the write to file method and it
said writing complete so just to
show you the reference back again this
is what we read sample.jpg and c drive
and if i go to the f drive java
tutorials where i provided the output
location i do see an outdoor jpg here
which which was not there earlier and if
i double click on this it's exactly the
same image so java was able to read the
image and render the exact same image by
converting that 2d byte array
representation back to an image exactly
the same for there's no change in this
image so this was a very short
enlightening tutorial for you to show
you how you can use image handling
classes for example the image io class
and the buffered image class to do basic
image handling operations obviously you
can do more complex operations with it
as well but for the demonstration
purpose i've just kept it simple let's
get started with concurrency utilities
in java now concurrency is a huge topic
and it's not possible to cover this into
a 10 or 15 minutes tutorials so treat
this particular session as an
introductory session where i will talk
about some of the most relevant classes
which you need to know when you talk
about concurrency we have been talking
about this whole concept of concurrency
programming throughout the thread
tutorials as well and the basic idea is
that you would like to do multiple
things at the same time that's the basic
idea now in that context java does
provide lot of utilities and packages
especially the
java.util.concurrent package is one of
the most popular package which you need
to use whenever you are dealing with
concurrency programming paradigms in
java so with that let's have a look at
what does this
java.util.concurrent package contains so
broadly it contains lot of utility
classes which can be very useful for you
when you are writing the concurrent
programming code apart from that it will
also provide some basic ideas around the
locking functionality and the atomic
packages as well when we talk about
locks again we discussed about locks
when we talked about the whole sync
thread synchronization concept as well
and it basically marries very well with
the whole concept of locks and atomic
packages as well atomic is again a
different topic which is used for thread
safe types basically but whenever you
will hear about concurrency utilities be
it in your discussions or be it in your
interviews you will be seeing a
discussion happening around executors
you will hear these terms like executors
executor service future completable
future callable all of these you will
hear the name of all of these classes
quite frequently so we these classes
were first introduced in java 8 and have
been there since then to support the
concurrency programming paradigm so i
will talk about these three classes
broadly in today's session and we'll
have a look at a demonstration of these
three classes as well uh let's first
talk about executor technically it's an
it's an interface it's not a class
though i said that it's a class but it's
basically an interface an executor is
basically a very simple interface which
will help you define the sub systems
which you want to which you would like
to create with the help of threads may
be including thread pools or if you want
to do a disk reading and writing
operation in an insynchronous way or you
want to create some sequence of task
frameworks as well so executor will
provide you a very lightweight framework
to do all of that especially around
thread pooling and asynchronous io is is
where it shines most because in your
computer you have limited resources and
you would like to uh dedicate a certain
pool of threads for a particular task or
for a particular executor object so with
that and the second class which we would
like to know about his executor service
an executor service will provide a more
asynchronous task execution framework
and this is probably the class which you
will be using whenever you're dealing
with asynchronous programming in java
asynchronous programming basically means
that you submitted a particular task but
you did not wait for it to be completed
you did not hang your process or your
thread for that particular task to be
completed it's very simple it's very uh
easy to relate this to a real life for
example if you are
you know there are times when you do two
things at the same time for example uh
let's take a very very simple example if
you're just boiling milk on on your gas
stove so you put the milk on the gas
stove and then you move out for a couple
of minutes to do some something else for
example maybe checking your mobile for
new emails or or doing some other work
doing maybe just doing some laundry so
uh you are doing you you submitted the
milk boiling task then you moved away
from that task because you know that
this particular task is going to take
some time and you utilize your time
somewhere else that's what we mean by
asynchronous programming and executor
service will provide you with constructs
to create a similar behavior in your
java program as well so remember about
executor and executor service uh we will
look at the implementations later where
we can talk about that another
interesting class which i would not
which i would like to talk about is
future if we have it here yeah so future
is another class which we will be
looking at and future is basically uh to
fetch the result of the submitted task
again taking the same knife example of
the milk boiling example so
it would be great right if if there is
some mechanism or some alarm which just
sets off the moment the milk is is is
boiling and it's about to be spilled out
it would be great to know that in that
in advance via some alarm or something
so future provides that kind of a
carrier or that kind of a
holder where you submitted a particular
task you moved your threads to something
else you did something else and then you
can check with the future object and
future object will tell the status of
that submitted task whether it is
completed or whether it's still in
progress once it is complete then you
can fetch the result of that submitted
task based on with the future object so
that's the concept of future so remember
executor service and future they will
work quite hand in hand because executor
service will be used to submit the task
and future will be able to fetch the
result of that particular task
asynchronously so that was about a quick
theory you can read more about it in the
documentation you can see in executor
service future class what does what does
this basically in this class do
but to have a look at or or get a
greater sense of this let's have a look
at our demonstration of it to understand
these classes better so let's move to uh
the eclipse ide to look at an example
let me close all the classes and just
open a relevant one so yeah so let's
first deal with the executor interface
itself so if i just minimize this one
here i've created a main class and i've
created a public static void main method
and you see two static methods here
executor invoke an executor service
invoke i'm basically showing you how you
can use executor and executor service so
if you're just using executor then how
you would do that is basically you are
going to create a reference of the
executor and then the executor needs a
basically an executor object because
it's an executor reference so you need
to supply an executor object so either
you can supply an inner class right here
or you can call you can create a
executor type of class which i've
created here which is called caller
class so i've created a class called
caller which implements the executor
type and execute the moment you write
implements executor it will force you to
override the execute method and inside
the execute method you are going to run
your own thread so this is how the
current thread or the executor's own
thread will be running so once you have
done the initialization then you can
call the execute method on the executor
class remember you got this object so
you can call the executor execute method
on the executor object here and inside
this you can provide this particular
lambda function implementation which is
going to ask you what exactly you want
to do when i run this particular thread
so when i run this thread when java runs
this particular thread what do you want
java to do that's something which you
will provide here so this is how you can
use it's a very simple example like i
said uh
this if i build a more complex example
it will take a lot of time and lot of
other concepts to cover so treat this as
an introductory session and you can
basically try to run a very simple
example of this writing whatever complex
logic you want to write while the thread
is running and put that into this
execute similarly if you if you want to
use executor service for doing the
asynchronous operations then it will
follow the same way but there are some
differences along the way as well so
this is the method which is showing the
executor service implementation or the
way of using executor service so again i
create a reference of executor service
and then here you see i'm saying
executors dot new fixed thread pool with
a size of 10. so that's the power of
executor service it is going to create a
pool of threads dedicated to itself to
do the tasks whichever are written
inside here so whatever you write here
these thread pool will be utilized to
execute that particular task you can
assign the size of the thread pool based
on how many threads you need there are
multiple static utility methods like
there is one new fixed thread pool which
i've used but if you just do control
enter you will see cached thread pool a
single thread execution a new work
stealing pool so like i mentioned there
are a lot of classes interesting classes
here which you can use for simplicity
i've just used a fixed thread pool here
once you get the executor service object
then here you called execute but here
you will be calling the submit method
and then the drill goes exactly the same
way that you write the lambda function
implementation inside here basically the
functional interface implementation and
you provide your own implementation code
which you would like to run whenever you
call the run method whenever this
executor service calls the run method on
that particular thread you can actually
go to the submit method and you will see
it accepts a runnable it basically
accepts a thread object so whatever you
write inside this particular code will
be the public void run implementation of
that particular thread class if you
don't
if you don't remember how threnable
works please go back to my threading uh
tutorial and watch that where i
explained the runnable interface and the
run method in detail so that's what we
are doing here so this is for executor
and this is for executor service so
let's run this program and yes i mean
nothing because i'm not doing anything
much apart from just doing sis outs here
and that's what you see here the
executor's example and the executor
service exam so this was about executor
and executor service now let's deal with
another interesting uh class of
of called future which i said that i
will also talk about so for that i have
created a separate demo because it
deserves a separate demo it's a very
interesting class so let me just make it
full screen yeah so i've created a class
called future demo which has a public
static void main method and again i'm
doing the
executor service initialization but this
time i'm using a new single thread
executor now what does this does this
this will basically create an executor
which will use a single worker thread
operating from an unbounded queue
remember even if this single thread
terminates due to let's say a failure
during the execution before the before
the graceful shutdown a new one will
automatically be spawned and will take
its place if the execution is still
pending so that's the power of single
worker thread from an unbounded queue
that's what i've used here based on your
use case you can use other ones as well
like i mentioned earlier then
i have the executor service object with
me and similar to the previous example
i'm going to call the submit method and
inside this submit method i need to
provide the runnable class runable
interfaces implementation and that
implementation will basically be of the
public void run method and this is what
i want to do in my run method where i'm
sleeping the thread for 10 seconds
thread.sleep method takes milliseconds
values as the parameter so this is 10
000 which means 10 seconds so i'm
sleeping this thread or pausing this
thread for 10 seconds and then returning
a string called completed this is what i
am doing in the executor service dot
submit implementation the result of it
is going to be a future object remember
the result of the submit task is going
to be a future object so i store that
future reference here and then at line
20 i'm using the same feature of a
future object to ask java to check if
this task is done and the way you do
that is just by calling is done so till
the time there's a negation condition
till the time the task is still in
progress because this mean future is not
done because i've put a negation then
just print this out there where you say
the task is still in progress it's still
not complete and you pause this
particular thread remember this was a
different thread if you you pause this
particular thread for 500 millisecond or
basically half a second and you again
check this condition if it's still not
done you print this again pause for half
a second again check this till the time
feature dot is done becomes true when
future dot is done becomes true that
means that this particular task is
completed now you see i mean generally
when we execute the programs the
execution happens sequently sequentially
that after line 17 the control will
automatically flow to line 20 and before
the control can reach line 20 everything
above line 17 has to be completed that's
that's basically synchronous programming
for you but when you talk about
asynchronous programming using the power
of executor service and future objects
we can do something here which will go
into a separate thread and then you can
continue your execution here so this can
be in a different method altogether
where you submit something and this is
basically checking the status of this
task understand this very well this is
very important concept that it's not a
it's though it's a sequential execution
after line 17 line 20 is getting
executed but line 20 is not waiting for
everything above line 17 to be finished
it will continue that's the power of
asynchronous programming so here we are
checking this and once the feature dot
future dot is done says true then we say
task completed we and then you probably
would like to fetch the result of this
particular task right and for that
future provides a method called future
dot get this is going to pick the future
object state and whatever you are
returning from here will be returned
here and then i'm printing the result so
if everything went fine this result
should say completed because that's what
i'm returning from this future object
and always remember to shut down your
executor service to release the thread
pool which you created here i've also
put a catch block here because i'm using
the third dot sleep method which will
ask you to handle an interrupted
exception and then there is an executor
service exception which is execution and
a timeout exception as well there are
other interesting methods as well on the
future class future object sorry which
is like future.cancel where you can
cancel explicitly a future task which is
currently in progress you can check the
status of it by calling is done which
i've used here you can also call is
cancel to check if the user or some
other process explicitly cancelled the
execution of the submission of the
executor service task so hope this is
you are able to understand the flow of
it that these block and these block will
program will execute them but they will
run in different threads so let's see
what happens now i'm going to run this
particular program and if i bring this
here you see the task still in progress
keeps getting called so we submitted the
task here and now this block is getting
executed this block kept getting
executed so this task did not finish
right the thread.sleep was this this
thread this whole thread was sleeping
for 10 second but line 20 did not wait
for 10 seconds it continued execution
and it kept checking the future object
10 times at least or till the whole 10
second sleep was taken away and one once
that once this thread woke up it
returned completed feature dot is done
became true and it came out and it said
task completed so that's what we get
here and at the end in the result you
get completed which is which is what you
returned from here so this is the power
of asynchronous programming please like
i mentioned please do read about more
about these classes and how they work
and what is the paradigm of asynchronous
programming it does make debugging a bit
hard at times but it's a very
interesting concept to be used in
concurrent applications let's get
started with regular expressions or
regex in java you may hear people
calling it as regex or regex doesn't
matter you can call it anything as as
you want till the time you have the
concept understood in the right way i'll
just call it as regex so when we talk
about regex let's understand why do we
need them and what are how java actually
provides support for that so the basic
idea behind regular expressions is is to
find a pattern in a in a text corpus if
you have lot of strings available if you
have any kind of text any kind of string
and if you would like to find a
particular pattern saying okay
does this whole text paragraph contains
any character or contains any number or
contains any special characters or
contains characters after numbers or
numbers after characters so if you would
like to find those kind of patterns in
in your text corpus then you can then
that concept is called regular
expression finding and java provides the
support for that particular regular
expression finding through a package
called
dot java.util.regex package so this is
the package which you would need to use
when you want to do any kind of regular
expression finding in that text now you
may want you may be thinking that why do
i need to use this i already have the
string handling methods right you can do
substring you can find a particular
character in the string etc but that is
limited because it only and only
provides string methods ways to
manipulate and find and replace strings
but regex is generic you can literally
find any kind of character in your
string it can be a special character it
can be a square bracket it can be a
multiply sign it can be a divide sign it
can be like i said integer
capital letters small case letters so
any kind of pattern you would like to
find
java.util.x can be used to find that
kind of pattern now this package is very
interesting and it provides lots of
classes and again this is a very very
very big topic and very complex topic so
we will just scratch the surface of it
and like i always say whenever you would
like to read more about it go back and
read the documentation currently the
documentation i've opened is for version
8 but when you are reading it you can go
for the latest java edition uh
documentation so with that let's talk
about some of the interesting classes
which we will be dealing with and we
must know when we talk about regex in
java so i already explained what are
regular expressions uh let's go to the
interesting classes the first class
which we need to know about is the
pattern class so pattern class or an
object of the pattern class will
basically be representing a compiled
regular expression so you write your
regular expression in a certain way
regular expression has its own language
i would say to write the pattern for
example if you would like to write a
pattern saying that find a
check if this particular text paragraph
has the characters first then the
integers then the characters then this
particular special character so that is
your pattern you write that pattern then
you need to compile that pattern to
compile that pattern you can use the
pattern class this this class generally
does not provide any kind of public
constructors to you so you cannot
initialize the pattern object explicitly
but to create a pattern you first you
need to basically call the static
methods a static method named as compile
so compile is the method which you need
to use to compile your regular
expression which will then return the
pattern object once you have compiled
your written your pattern and you
compile your pattern the next class
which you need to know about is the
matcher class matcher class will provide
that particular engine framework which
will understand and interpret the
pattern and then will try to find that
pattern on the text paragraph which
you're supplying and it will result in
true or false if it finds that pattern
it will say true if it's not finding the
pattern it will say false so that's the
basic idea so you need to you need to
know about the pattern class and you
need to know about the matter class so
it also does not the matcher class also
does not provide any kind of public
constructors and you obtain a matcher
object by calling the matcher method on
the pattern object so once you created a
pattern object just call the matcher on
that particular object and that will get
you a matcher object and it then you can
use that object to find the patterns in
that particular text corpus there is
also a dedicated exception which is
called pattern syntax exception which
will be
thrown whenever you have written the
regular expression syntax incorrectly
like i said it has it has its own
language so you need to write the
expression in a way regular expressions
are supposed to be written and supposed
to be understood i will touch upon that
in a while but that's that's the basic
idea about the three classes now when
when you would like to find a pattern it
can be a string pattern it can be some
characters it can be some predefined
characters some quantifiers you can also
create sub groups within the regular
expression so there is a like i said
there is a tons of functionality which
is available in this particular concept
and we will just cover some of the
relevant ones or just just run through
some of these concepts and then i will
switch to a demonstration for example if
you talk about the string literals then
you can do the string matching for
example if you want to find this
particular word or this pattern this is
just a text pattern right so if you
would like to find this particular text
pattern in the text string then you can
write this particular text pattern as a
string pattern inside the pattern object
so that's that's about the string
literals now let's move to some
interesting ones like like meta
characters and the meta characters are
very interesting because they have a
special meaning for example if you write
your regular expression like this where
you say cat and then you say dot then
when you are applying this particular
regular expression to find the match
into a string it is only going to find
the match for c a t it is not going to
find the match for c a t dot because dot
is a meta character in regular
expression it has a special meaning it
it does not mean dot but it has a
special meaning and that special meaning
basically means that even though the dot
is not present it will basically mean
that after cat it can be any character
so the meta character dot means any
character which is why you see this
match succeeds because it will search
for this pattern which it matches and
after that it can be any character it
doesn't care so even if it's s or d or
whatever it will say true because c80
was found a match so dot means any
character after the pattern you have
specified similarly there are a lot of
other characters special characters are
meta characters like the ones which have
been listed here question mark star plus
dot on and all of these have their own
dedicated special meaning they are not
your your normal uh arithmetic operators
or other operators they have their
special meaning when you are dealing
with meta characters so do read about
them in detail and i will be using a bit
of meta characters in the example as
well then the character classes are also
very interesting uh similar to the
example which i told you before if you
want to find a particular string or a
particular integer into a into a text
corpus then you can use the character
class patterns for example you just put
a square brackets and you write abc this
means that it will try to find exactly a
b c in the string if you put a cap in
front of abc then it will try to match
any character or find any character
except a b or c so it's a negation
similarly if you specify small a to z
and capital a to z it means any
character can be there between small
case a to z and capital case a to z a to
z inclusive similarly you can provide
specific ranges like a through d or m
through p so only the characters which
will match the union of this condition
will be returning true and rest of the
if that if this particular pattern is
violated then you will get false so
similarly there are you can build lot of
complex combinations and permutations
with these
special meta characters and character
classes do read about these in detail if
you are curious to know about it and
there is tons of materials available on
this on internet which you can read
about to learn more about similarly
there are predefined character classes
as well dot is something which i already
explained which means any character then
you can use slash d to find a digit in a
particular string or a particular text
corpus slash capital d is for non-digit
or you can use the classic negation
condition as well slash s is for a white
space character slash capital s is for a
non-white space character word non-word
so there are a lot of different examples
so i think by now you would have built a
decent understanding of what i'm trying
to tell you is that you can specify
these patterns compile them and then use
the matcher so let's move to a very
simple demonstration it's not a complex
example but very simple example just to
get the point across so i'm creating a
regex string here and this is the
pattern i've specified i'm saying any
character star means any number of
characters so it can be anything here
then the string the the pattern expects
an alphabetical
string or alphabetical section after
that the alphabetical section should be
followed by a numerical section and
after the numerical section again it can
be any character so this is my pattern i
create a simple string with this regex
pattern and like i mentioned in the
documentation you call pattern.compile
to compile the regular expression so i
compile the regular expression i get the
pattern object and after again as per
the documentation it said that you can
call the matcher method on the pattern
object to get a matcher object so i say
pattern dot matcher and i provide my
string on which i want to test it so
i've just put a random string where
there are some integers then there is
some alphabets and then again there are
some integers once you have got the
matcher object just call matcher.find
this will return a boolean where you can
test whether the uh the matcher
found a hit in the text corpus or not if
it found a match the match found will be
true and if it didn't found find the
match you will get a false value in this
result so with that understanding let's
run this program so i get the output
match found why did i get that because i
said that start with anything so it
started with anything i don't care what
it is it's an integer or any special
character i don't care after that there
should be some alphabets so there are
some alphabets and right after alphabets
there should be some numbers so again
there are some numbers and after that
there can be any character 0 or more
character so there is nothing here
that's why you see a match found let's
do an interesting test here let me do
this i put a to z again here so now i'm
saying start with anything have
alphabets have numbers and again after
numbers you should have some alphabet
which is not the case here because you
start with something you have alphabets
you have numbers and after numbers the
string ends there is nothing after that
so let's see what happens now you get a
match not found because this particular
pattern when got compiled and got
applied on this particular string did
not find the string following the regex
pattern which we have specified so this
is a very simple example to show you how
you can build patterns you can use
groups concepts as well to group the
patterns it can get very very complex
and very very nasty so use them very
wisely very carefully uh and do read
about the documentation and other
examples which i talked about to get
more understanding and more comfortable
with regex let's get started with nio
packages in java now let's first
understand why why do we need this
package and where will be using this
package let's talk about the ware first
you can use the nio package to read from
a file or write to a file now let's talk
about the why because the obvious
question will be that we already have
the i o package in java right where you
can where you can use the classes from
that particular package to read from a
file or write to a file then why do we
need
an another package doing exactly the
same thing as an io so the basic reason
for launching the java.nio package was
providing the multi-threading
capabilities to the io library and we
could not do this in the existing io
library because we had to probably
rewrite and change the functionality of
it that's why java created a new library
called new package called java.nio
package and this package is basically
i mean if you if you understand what nio
means here generally as per the popular
perception it means non-blocking io that
you don't want to block your threads
while you're reading to a file or
writing to a file classically niu meant
networking io but as per the popular
perception people know is know it as
non-blocking i o so the basic idea is
because whenever you are read reading a
file or writing to a file the thread
gets blocked until the whole file is
written or until the whole file is red
so the nio package provides an
improvement over that it provides an
improvement in a way that you can read
the file into a different thread but at
the same time move on to an another
thread and right to a file so you get
this multi-threading capabilities and
non-blocking capabilities out of the box
from the classes provided by java.nio
package so that's the brief about this
package now some of the popular classes
which you will be dealing with and some
of the concepts which you need to know
about niu package are buffers and
channels these this is probably the core
concept of the whole nio package of how
channels and buffers work so let's say
you are trying to read something then
the read operation will be happening
from the channel into the buffer and
similarly the write operation will be
happening in the reverse way which means
to the channel from the buffer so that's
how the buffer and channel work together
that whenever you are trying to write
something you have to first open a
channel create a buffer and then you can
read from the channel into the buffer
and similarly when you're writing to the
buffer you again have to go via the
channel route so channel is that route
basically buffer is basically just a
plain container for the data and channel
is basically representing the connection
to the entities which are capable of
performing the iu operation so think of
channels as as a pipe a
channel literally basically if you if
you understand the english meaning of
channel that's exactly what we mean by
here that it provides just a means to an
end it provides sort of a wire to the
buffer and then you also have selectors
and selection keys classes which
together with selection channels work to
provide the non-blocking i o
functionality there are some other apis
uh interesting apis as well like
cassette and some more but i will not go
into the detail of that because if you
know about buffers and channels and
selectors then we will be able to figure
out what exactly we would like to do
with this i would also like to talk a
bit more about the buffer class so if
you go to the buffer classes operations
the popular operations you will see
there will be the read operation which
is for reading the files basically or
reading the content of the file this
works on the byte stream concept first
of all so it to read the bytes from the
file you will call the read method
there's also a very interesting method
called flip which i will be using which
makes a buffer ready for the new
sequence of operations so once you have
done something and you want to let's say
you read a particular file and you have
come to the end of the file now you
would like to reset the buffer and go
back to the beginning of the file then
you can use the flip method for that
particular piece to the uh to bring the
current position back to the position or
to the zero index or to the starting of
the file so that's about read and flip
and we will have a look at some of the
other methods and there are a lot of
interesting classes in this niu package
do read read about the documentation and
check out the other methods as well to
learn more about this package but the
basics are like i said channels buffers
some methods of the buffers and there's
also a path class which is used to
basically provide a particular path to a
directory which i will not be covering
in this example but something good to
know so with that understanding let's
move to an example and understand how we
can work around with this an io package
so for that i have prepared an example
where i will be writing a reading from a
file and then writing to a file so i
have a main method here the first
section here basically is about reading
from a file and the second section is
about writing to a file so let's go
through all of both of these sections
one by one to understand what is
happening so in the read section i use
the file input stream class from the i o
package i'm still not using the paths
class here just to show you that both to
both of them still can work together if
you want to use the old constructs so
use the same file input construct to
read a file called source.txt which is
present at this particular location in
my directory and this source.txt has has
just a one line of text nothing more so
i i basically create the file input
stream object and then i create a
channel because we are dealing with
files so you create a file channel if
you're dealing with network socket then
you might have a socket channel so
that's also something which you need to
know about that this nio package is is
generic it can be used for any kind of
communication of reading and writing not
specifically to file handling so we
create a file channel object here by
calling file input stream dot get
channel it's that simple once you call
that you will get a reference or the
object basically of the file channel
then the next thing is to create the
buffer like you mentioned that channels
and the buffer are the two main tools
through which you work with an nio
library so we create a byte buffer and
we allocate some starting size to it
just some some threshold size so you can
put it any number which you think is
practical for your file and your for the
use case here i've put just one zero two
four bytes or one megabyte because my
file is pretty small so i just put that
and initialize the red read buffer and
then i call read channel dot read
operation so the file channel object you
created you just call the read method on
this particular channel and supply the
buffer and then it is going to read the
file wire the channel into the buffer
and this read method is going to return
a result to denote if the file was
written successfully or not i'm just
pointing printing assist out here just a
bare bones is out nothing new here so
this section will be used to read a file
so let's see if i can read the file
successfully and then we'll move to the
right section so i go to run as java
application yeah it says file read
successfully and it read 27 bytes it
means that there were total of 27 bytes
in my in my file which had a single line
of text so it read all of that and it it
completed the execution now let's move
to the right section and i can comment
the read section because we have covered
that so here i'm again creating a file
output stream object because i need to
write something so again using the same
construct of the i o package i have
covered previously in the previous
sessions once you have the file output
stream object created the next thing is
to create a channel so i i again create
a file channel but this time it's the
right channel i again create a buffer
which is the right buffer allocate some
size to it then this is the string which
i want to write to this particular file
so my file my destination file will be
called dest.txt will be present in this
particular location and this file should
have this string written if this whole
operation goes successfully that's my
end goal so to do that i say
writebuffer.put
and whatever string you have created
just call get bytes on it and you get a
bytes representation of the whole string
so that's what i've done here because
this put method expects byte because if
you go inside this it expects a byte
array so that's what i'm supplying here
i'm providing the uh the byte array by
on the string by calling message.getbyte
or any string object.getbytes will get
your byte array once you've done that
then i'm calling the flip method
remember i talked about this flip method
to basically reset the index that's
something which you need to do in this
particular case so that the index goes
back to the initial position and the
buffer can be written successfully to a
file uh to a channel basically so once
the buffer is is comp has completed its
operation then i can write the buffer to
the channel and once that is done then
if those if these operations went
successfully then i will see a file
called dest.txt in this particular
directory currently there is no desk.txt
in this directory you can see there are
just three files but there is no
test.txt so let's run this program so it
says file written successfully which was
the last sysout at line 28 but let's
also see what is happening in the
directory so now i see a desk.txt
popping up here it's a 1kb file
and if i double click on this i see the
same string which is which say this is a
test string which is the same string
which i supplied here so you can see you
can use the nio packages to do the file
read and write and much much more than
just read and write using the niu
package but this is just to get get the
point across that this can be done using
the nio or the non blocking io package
as well so that you get maximum
performance on your machine while you
deal with file io operations let's get
started with java beans so we have been
creating java classes and creating
objects of those java classes to work
and manipulate transfer data call
methods create properties etc and java
beans just use that as the groundwork to
create a specification first of all
let's understand that java beans is just
a standard it is just a specification
which has been provided by by java to be
followed while you are implementing
production grade or enterprise grade
applications so it's just a pure
specification set of standards if you
want to read more about this please go
to this particular link which is written
here i mean if you just google java bean
spec oracle then you will be able to
find this particular link you will see a
download option here if you go here you
will get these two specification
documents option so you can just accept
the license agreement and click on this
particular beans 0 1 1 0 1 pdf and you
can read about the whole java bean
specification i have already downloaded
this particular pdf which is opened in
this tab and if you go to the toc here
it's an official sun microsystem white
paper basically and if you read about
this this this is going to explain the
whole java beans api specifications it's
going to specify the core components of
the java beans component architecture so
it's a specification let's understand
that very well if you go to the table of
contents let's go to the interesting one
which says what is exactly a bean or a
java bean so a java bean is basically a
reusable software component that can be
manipulated in any visual ide like
eclipse or intellij or netbeans etc so
technically a java bean is just a java
class but that java class should follow
three main properties the first property
is that that java class should have
getters and setters to access the
properties second property is that that
java class should have a public no
argument constructor so that anybody can
create an object of it and third is that
the java class should implement
serializable the reason in java being
specified these three conditions which i
said so let's talk about the third one
where we are talking we are saying that
it should be implementing serializable
interface why is that it's because a
java bean would be required to be
exported between applications may be
required to be written to a database or
to a file system or to be converted into
an xml or a json document sent over the
network again being deserialized so this
will be moving across a lot because
that's what we mean by reusable multiple
different software components and
applications might be reusing that bean
again and again and that beat needs to
travel across and to enable that that
bean has to be serializable because if
you can't serialize it you just cannot
transport that object to another
application it's just not possible this
is how java has been so that's why you
need to implement serializable you need
to have a public no argument constructor
and you need to have getters and setters
to access your properties you can
actually read more about this if you
scroll down it will also talk about the
difference between beans and class
libraries remember not class but class
libraries and here it explains what i
just said that a java bean can have
properties it can have events and it can
have methods so properties are nothing
but the normal attributes which you
create inside java class nothing fancy
the same attributes are named as
properties for example you may have a
foreground property and then you can
have a method which is just a normal
java method which can be called from
other applications or from an
environment and by default all of the
beans public methods will be exported by
exported i meant when you export this
when you serialize and export this
object all the beans public methods will
be exported by default but then a bean
can choose to export only a subset of
its methods if it wants to a bean can
also have events and events basically
provide a way for one object to notify
other objects that something has
happened so something similar to the uh
to the producer consumer example or the
producer consumer pattern where uh you
can notify other objects threads also
have this particular pattern where a
thread can notify other threads that it
has completed its task and other threads
can start so uh so this is so that's the
property behind event where something
has occurred and then the object can
tell other objects that's that and that
something has occurred so that they can
react to that particular event so these
are the three main uh
traits which are properties events and
methods uh you can read more about this
particular white paper i will not go
into the details because it's a long
white paper but it's a very well written
white paper which will give you a very
good understanding of how java bean
specification was written what was the
thought process behind it so coming back
to the code if you want to just write it
it can be very simple to write just
write any class and say implements
serializable so it will ask you to
provide a cl version usual id so you can
write this here then you can create your
attributes as normal private attributes
you can create public methods to access
and manipulate these attributes in the
forms of getters and setters so these
are the public methods to to access and
manipulate these attributes here we have
a parameterized constructor which will
not be required or which should not be
there when you're creating a java beam
it should just be like this because when
we talk about the public know args
constructor as we discussed in the very
first lectures that
you do not need to provide the default
constructor java will automatically
provide a default constructor for every
class so you don't need to write
something like this it's just not needed
because you can write it but it has no
value attached it has no meaning because
this is something exact this kind of
code is already generated by java
compiler when it compiles this
particular class so a public default no
argument constructor implementing
serializable private properties and
public methods and you can have
additional event methods as well which i
talked about just when we were going
through the white paper and that's all
pretty much what a java bean is so you
can see it's it's just a java class but
some additional uh specifications which
a java class has to follow to be called
as a javabean let's get started with
spring framework so spring framework is
the most popular web application
framework available out there today and
all of the big companies from netflix to
whatnot use spring framework to build
the modern day java applications so
before we go any further let's
understand why do we need a framework so
let's understand this with the help of a
diagram so let me just open a blank
paint page and let me show you what i
mean by a framework and why do we need
this so we built simple applications so
far but if you have to build a
enterprise grade web application you
will have a front end probably where you
will have what you see in the browser so
you will have the html the javascript or
or any other
java enterprise edition classes like gsp
servlet etc then you will have a back
end where your java classes are present
which contains the business logic so the
business logic and then you have a
database where you have the you store
the basic basically the whole data so
you have these three different layers we
also call this a three tier architecture
so you cannot build all of this by just
using the core java classes which we
talked about
you need to
do more integrations you need to use
more different programming languages and
concepts to build a complete enterprise
grid application and if you try to build
all of this by yourself then it's going
to take a lot of time and lot of effort
that's why we have frameworks which
basically create provide the structure
to create these three layers so that's
why we have this frameworks and in the
frameworks spring is the most popular
framework it provides the structure to
write all these these three layers one
of the reasons i did not talk about the
the java enterprise edition technologies
like servlets and gsps because nobody
works on them today even if you learn
about servlet it's good to know the
conceptual overview of servlets but
nobody today builds applications on jsps
and servlets that's the reason i did not
talk about it because today we have
sophisticated front-end frameworks like
angularjs or react.js or amber.js and
whatnot and it is hydrating at a very
faster speed so there is literally
practically no need for a java developer
today to learn about gsp because i can
bet you on that you can take it in
written from me nobody is going to build
the gsp app based applications in 2021
everybody is going to use some sort of
front-end framework to build that and
then you have a back-end in the back end
you have the exact core java classes
like i just explained so you will be
using the java beans and you will be
basically using the pure java concepts
of collections and and etc to write the
backend logic using the java classes and
then you will need a jdbc connection to
write to a database as well so you would
need a database as well and spring
provides connectors and
specifications to support all of these
three layers that's the reason so
generally when you talk about a web
application let's talk about web
application because java primarily is
used in web applications so in a web
application you basically see a browser
window where you load a particular page
but what happens behind the scene this
browser has some html and some js maybe
and this code is basically calling some
endpoint this endpoint is present in the
backend layer so this endpoint is
present in the backend layer that end
point transfers the control to the
business layer where you have your core
business logic return and then the
business layer
transfers the control to the
data layer or some people also call it
dow layer this dow layer then talks to
the database that's how a web
application works and that's what that's
the architecture you will mostly be
following whenever you are building any
enterprise grid application in any
organization so spring provides support
for all of these parts this obviously is
written by angular and react and other
frameworks but this is this whole
section is basically presented or
supported by spring so with that let's
understand a bit more about spring
framework so if you go to the spring
official website it talks about some of
the value propositions spring is used
heavily like i said it's used everywhere
it's very flexible framework there are a
couple of concepts which spring provides
which is around inversion of control and
dependency injection and i will talk
about these concepts in a while uh when
we'll talk more about the springs
components it makes uh it's quite
productive and quite fast as well so
it's very fast to build application on
on spring it has a whole dedicated
security module as well so it's quite
secure by design and the spring
community is huge so you can find lot of
support on internet let's learn bit more
about the springs core components or
core technologies so if you talk about
the spring score components these are
the springs core components so you have
a testing module you have you have a
core module first of all inside the
techno in the core components you have a
core module which has ioc containers
resources events i'll talk a bit about
that it has a it has its own testing
component so it provides very good
support for testing applications it has
a data access component the data access
component is used to provide connections
utilities to the database because like i
mentioned your application will be
talking to the database and spring
provides a
complete dedicated component to be used
whenever you are dealing whenever you
are talking to the database it also
provides a web servlet component to
provide support for spring mvc which i
will be covering in the next session web
sockets and storm and messaging
frameworks etc it also supports reactive
or asynchronous programming if you want
to do that it provides a lot of
integration capabilities in the
integration modules if you want to do
jms or jmx or email or task scheduling
etc and it also provides language
support to support internationalized
internationalization of the applications
so
it has a lot of different components but
we will focus on this core component
which is of the interest here so let's
talk about that the first thing which
you need to know about string is its
support for inversion of control and it
provides that support by creating an
inversion of control container what do
we mean by inversion of control the
basic idea is let me
take any random example and i will be
able to communicate the idea behind this
so let's go to any simple example which
i have already covered let's go to
method calling for example so we had a
student class we created a student class
simple student class three properties
constructor and public getters and
setters and then i created a main class
and i initialized the student object so
to the responsibility of creating the
student object lies with the student
class itself student class have to be
explicitly initialized to be having an
object of the student so this creates a
problem because when you're dealing with
enterprise grade frameworks you might
need to create lot of objects on the fly
whenever the
end point is talking to the business
layer
if i take the reference of this
architecture if the endpoint is talking
to the business layer classes business
layer classes are talking to the data
access layer classes so when the
business layer classes needs to talk to
the data access layer classes the data
access layer classes needs to have an
object because that communication
happens between objects only so who
creates those objects if every time the
data access object has been has been
called and if we provide if we pass that
responsibility to the dao class to
create the object or every time the
endpoint talks to the business class we
ask the business layer to create the
objects it becomes a lot of painful
process because every time you will be
doing this new student everywhere you
need a student object which is very
painful process so what spring says it
says okay involve the control of
creating the object so let's not give
the responsibility of creating the
object to the class let's give that
responsibility to the framework so the
framework will be responsible for
creating the objects of a class and it's
not the class who will be responsible
for creating its own objects so
generally outside the framework a class
is responsible for getting its object
but with spring spring inverts this
responsibility that's why we call it
inversion of control the control is
inverted it's reversed and now it's the
framework responsibility to create the
objects you will also hear about a
concept called dependency injection a
lot in context of ioc and dependency
injection is an implementation of the
ioc concept so using springs dependency
injection mechanism you can inject the
object of any class into any class once
you do that string dependency is going
to use the inversion of control concept
and create the object that's about ioc
and di or dependency injection then the
other modules like resources will
provide a way to refer different files
and properties if you want to then you
have a validation module as well which
will provide different validation
constructs because once you receive the
data you might need to run a lot of
validation right and writing the
validation by yourself can be very
painful so it provides a validation
framework as well by providing the
validator interface you can use this
particular framework to write the
validation rules checking the name not
empty etc similarly it also supports an
expression language if you want to use
that so the expression language support
is wide very wide in fact you can create
an expression parser and you can do the
expression language evaluation using the
uh a spring expression language
similarly it also provides support for
aspect-oriented programming now again
all these concepts of validation and
spring expression language and resource
support the you probably would need
hours of reading to learn about these
concepts and i'm just running through
them just to tell you about these
concepts and do read about why do you
need resources why do you want to do
validation why do you need an expression
language what is aspect oriented
programming read about all of those
concepts because they are not related to
java they are generic concepts which
will be applicable to any programming
language so any enterprise application
you build in any programming language
you would need to do the validation you
would need to do the resource reference
management you would need to have an
expression language you would need to
have aspect-oriented programming support
so this is just to tell you that that
java does provide an aop or
aspect-oriented programming support as
well and it has a lot of
apis available for that along with that
it also provides very good logging
capabilities because you definitely need
to log all the actions which the
framework or your objects are taking so
this was a very quick lightning overview
about spring i understand it's not
possible to cover all the concept of a
framework as sophisticated and as smart
as spring in in a 10 to 15 minutes
lecture so treat this as an introduction
session and like i said read more about
all of these components i just explained
the core because this is this is sort of
the main building block of spring
framework and then you have other
supporting uh components as well so do
check out the documentation there are
tons of examples available in fact in
the springs official website itself if
you go to the spring guide section if
you go to the
loan and you go to the guide section
there are awesome getting started and
topical guides and tutorials available
so for example how to build a restful
web service how to schedule tasks how to
consume a restful web service how to
build a simple java project with maven
how to upload files with string how to
do messaging with readies which is
basically a caching framework how to do
messaging using spring to rabbit mq
rabbit mq is a messaging framework so
there are tons of examples available
here very good documentation very robust
documentation do check out the examples
to learn more about this let's get
started with mvc and the implementation
of mvc using spring so before we go any
further let's first understand what do
we mean by an mvc application so in the
previous lectures i discussed about the
three tier application where you had a
presentation layer you had a business
layer and then you had a database layer
which is talking to the database and
that's how we built a three-tier
application which can also evolve into
an n-tier application but when when the
web development started the most popular
concept which came out was
m v c m stands for model v stands for
view and c stands for controller so the
idea was that these three components
together can render a web application
and how they render the web application
is basically that the controller is
going to receive the request which is
coming from the web browser then the
controller will have the knowledge of
where the business logic for that
particular request will be residing so
the controller is going to invoke the
model the corresponding model which is
required to execute the business logic
of the request and the controller will
also have the knowledge of what response
page to be sent back to the user so we
are talking about the response page here
not response remember that because it's
a web application so the model view
controller architecture basically was
designed uh to keep in mind that you
have a web application where a request
is coming from and you need to process
some business logic and then you need to
return back with a page response which
is going to be displayed on the web
browser of the client machine so that's
why we had these three components as
model view and controller controller
taking up the request then finding the
right model for it which can execute the
business logic and then also finding the
right view for it which can render the
business logic processed by the model so
that's a quick overview about model view
controller or mvc architecture do read
about it in detail to understand how
this works but like i mentioned that mvc
the most popular mvc implementation is
provided by spring spring is the most
popular mvc framework and the way spring
implements it is something which i have
drawn already here so let's understand
how this works so first the request
comes from the web browser and spring
has uh the a very first welcome servlet
which is called dispatcher servlet any
request which is coming to the spring
enabled web application will first hit
dispatcher servlet and once the request
comes to the dispatcher servlet the
dispatcher servlet has all the knowledge
of all the controllers of all the view
resolvers which i will talk about in a
while and of all the views as well it
also has knowledge about handler
mappings which again i will just discuss
now so the basic premise is that
dispatcher servlet is the component
which has knowledge about literally
everything happening in your application
and that's why dispatcher servlet is the
first servlet or the first component
which receives your web request so once
the request comes here first of all it
looks at the path and finds out the
right handler for it the right
controller for it and the way it does
that by using the handler mapping
component or handler mapping logic which
is provided out of the box by spring
framework so the handler mapping logic
will tell the dispatcher servlet which
particular controller is going to
process the request which is coming
because every request will have a
different controller return so whatever
the type of request is whatever the path
of the request is based on that the
dispatcher servlet is going to find a
particular controller once the
controller is found like i mentioned
earlier the controller will have
knowledge about the right model to
invoke for that particular request model
is nothing
but basically a java class holding the
business logic for this particular
request so it will invoke that java
class and get all the business logic
processed and then it is going to return
a model and view object view is here
simply pointing to the ui response which
you are going to send back to the user
it can be a jsp page it can be an html
page it can be any other view technology
so anything which is
which is used to render a web
application on a web page is view and
controller is going to send both the
model and view information back to the
dispatcher servlet the dispatcher
servlet will take the view part of it
and go to another component which is
again provided by spring which is called
view resolver the view resolver will
have the knowledge to see which
particular actual jsp or template to
invoke for the view value coming from
the controller so based on the value
which is returned by the controller a
view resolver is going to return the
right page mapping and once the
dispatcher servlet knows the page
mapping it is just going to invoke that
page by calling the view component so
dispatcher servlet handler mapping
controller view resolver and view these
five components together help render a
web mvc application in the spring
framework so that was about the theory
of how spring works now let's move on to
uh example to understand how this works
in action so here i have already built a
spring mvc application and if you're
wondering how to build that there's an
easy way to do that using spring
initializer and that's also the
recommended way actually if you go to
the documentation of spring you will see
that it recommends creating a new
project from
scratch using the spring initializer
utility which is provided by spring out
of the box so just go to web a web
browser and
type start dot spring dot io you will
get this page where you can specify what
type of project you want to create so it
is going to create the basic skeleton
for any spring application automatically
for you it's probably like i said it's
probably the fastest way to get started
with spring so we will choose a maven
project maven is again a dependency
management tool which is used to
download any kind of jars for your
application so we are going to use a
maven project and we want to create a
skeleton for a java application we are
going to use the latest released version
of spring or spring boot which is 2.4.2
it says spring boot here but don't get
confused with it we are going to use
just the mvc classes and not the spring
boot specific logic yet then you provide
your group artifact id and the name for
your jar you provide a description you
can provide a welcome package name
whatever suits you and then how you
would like to run your application
whether you would like to package your
application as a jar file which is a
java archive or you would like to run it
as a web archive which is a var file so
you can choose either packaging mode and
it is going to add appropriate
dependencies inside the project to
support the packaging of jar or the
packaging of war then you can also
choose a java version so you can see
there are three java versions listed
here which are 8 11 and 15 so whichever
java version you are working on you can
choose that particular version and once
you have set all with everything just
hit generate once you do that it is
going to create a project here and then
you can import this project just as a
normal project inside the eclipse ide
and that's exactly what i've done for
this initial project which is showing a
very basic hello world sort of example
for how spring mvc will work so this
whole structure will automatically be
created for you and like i said it was a
maven project and in every maven project
you will have a palm.xml if i double
click on this it is going to open this
xml and it will list down all the
dependencies which my project needs to
have let's understand the dependencies
as well so this project is currently
using the properties of 1.8 but that's
and that's fine you can obviously
definitely change this value i just kept
it as 1.8 for now because i'm not using
any new functionality yet in the
dependencies section you will see all
the dependencies or all the jars which
are required by the spring application
to run successfully the first dependency
we see here is about daimy leaf and
daimy leaf basically is a view
technology similar to jsp or similar to
servlets
technically where you can supply use
this daimy leaf templates which are
basically just htmls with some dynamic
values and you can use these dymy lift
templates to render web pages for your
spring mvc application if you want to
use some other view technology you need
to include the dependency of that view
technology here instead of dye my life
so that's about that then you need to
include the spring boot starter web the
spring boot starter web is going to
enable your application to become a web
application then this is this is a this
is basically a good to have dependency
which you can have in your project which
will help you deploy the project at
runtime automatically without restarting
the server because the web application
will be running on a server on a web
server basically or an application
server technically because it needs to
run somewhere so that it so that clients
can access it that's how a web client
architecture works or the server client
architecture works so this dependency
will allow you to deploy changes
dynamically at runtime without
restarting the server then this
dependency is for tests if you're
writing any unit tests and then you have
a plugin which will allow to run this
particular project with a single command
which we will see in a while so that's
about the dependency tour now let's look
at what is in the src main java in the
src main java i just have two classes
one is the main class which will have a
public static void main method and this
is the entry point of the spring
application and then i have a controller
class i already talked about what
controller is but i will come back to
that in a while let's understand the
rest of the files as well the next one
is src main resources where you will
have your view technology data available
like i mentioned it is using dye my leaf
templates currently and basically like i
said they are technically htmls with
some dynamic data so i've created a
templates folder under src main
resources which will automatically be
generated by spring initializer and then
under templates i have placed an html
file it's a pure html file with the only
difference is this value so this is what
the dynamic value means which which is
supported by dimer leaf templates
otherwise this is pure html it's just a
paragraph with a header and this is the
dynamic value which i am populating it
also has application.properties which
has nothing but you can use this
particular file to supply environment
specific properties for the development
environment or the testing environment
or the real production environment if
you have any unit tests those will go
here under src test java and this is the
system library already provided
supported by eclipse itself and i
already talked about the palm dot xml
you also see couple of more files
created by springboard if you want to
use that you can use that to run the run
the program from the command line as a
utility otherwise you can just use
ambient spring boot command which i will
show you in a while there's also a
gradle folder which you can ignore
probably we don't need this because we
are just using maven and we are not
using gradle gradle is another
dependency management tool very very
similar to maven so you can ignore this
folder right now so that's the structure
and now let's come back to the
controllers remember i told you that
controllers are the ones which receive
the request so from the dispatcher
servlet which i talked about here after
the dispatcher servlet the request comes
to the controller so once you hit a
particular url then you need to create a
controller for that url mapping remember
that you need to create a controller for
almost every url mapping you are having
in your application there should be some
mapping to some controller somewhere so
i've created a greeting controller and
the way you specify or you make a simple
class as a controller is by putting the
add the red controller annotation this
is the annotation which is supported by
spring and you can put this annotation
on top of any class and that class will
be treated as controller by spring and
the moment the moment you put this this
class will also be registered with the
dispatcher servlet and like i mentioned
the controller's main purpose is to
receive the requests the web requests
which are coming from the client and the
way you can receive the requests to a
controller by providing the exact url
mapping so if somebody runs this web
application and says
slash greeting then this particular
method should get invoked and how you
define that is with the get mapping
annotation use the get mapping
annotation to provide the url path
whenever somebody invokes this url path
this method would be getting called and
when this method is getting called at
that same time this url can also accept
some query parameters we call that as
the request parameters in in the spring
language so you can use the request
parameters as an annotation to provide a
placeholder for the variable for which
the value will be supplied in the url so
slash greeting if if you call this url
something like this
then it will work because you have a
variable called name which is which is
being parsed as a query string because
you have used the request paramentation
so we'll see an example of that when
once we run this application and how we
can supply the query string but you use
the request param annotation to supply
the query string parameters to the url
you can mention if the parameter is
mandatory or non-mandatory if the
required equal to true was there then
this parameter would be mandatory you
can also supply a default value if
somebody is if the client is not
providing this query parameter at all
would you like to set any default value
if yes you can supply the default value
here and then you just give a
placeholder name like i said then the
second argument which your your methods
which are intercepting the request
should have is the model argument and
remember i told you that the controller
will have what should have the knowledge
about the model and from here that
knowledge comes you this particular
method will expect you to provide a
model argument as well so if somebody
calls this application and provides the
urls with slash greeting this particular
method will get invoked and then the
code inside this method will be getting
executed so it's a very simple code
right now but this is where your whole
logic will go remember that but here i'm
just saying model dot add attribute name
with the value which is coming from the
query string parameter that's all i'm
doing here and
remember i told you that the model will
hold the business logic so here this is
the business logic where whatever query
string parameter which is coming from
the request param i'm capturing that and
i'm adding that value with the variable
name in the attributes of the model so
my model is set and after that i need to
return the view so that this particular
file name will be intercepted by the
view resolver here if you remember we
talked about the view resolver so when
we return
greetings as a string that string goes
here and then dispatcher servlet looks
out asks the view resolver to find a
particular html matching with this
particular text so view resolver is
going to look at under src main
resources slash templates to see if
there is a file with the name greeting
available or not since we have that file
available the spring is going to render
this particular file supplying the model
attribute value name now remember the
greeting.html had the exact same
variable name so this variable name
should exactly match with this variable
name here if you do if you make a
mistake here this is not going to work
because the model is holding the
business logic and i'm printing that
business logic inside the view using the
dye my lift template syntax which is
dollar curly braces so whenever you have
to print any variable or a model
attribute or any runtime value inside a
dhammalife template then you need to use
the dollar curly braces syntax to do
that so that was about a quick overview
of how this application is is written
right now and that's all the code is
here now it's time to run this
application so one of the simplest way
to run this application would be to
provide a spring at the run
configuration here for the spring
application or you can choose another
way which is to first have a look at the
spring web content application which is
the entry point so once your application
boots up this is the first line of code
which is going to get executed and to
make sure that this code works make sure
that you have the add the red spring
boot application annotation on top of
the entry point class so this is this is
sort of the mandate which spring will
force you to put in front of the or on
top of the entry point class to to treat
this class as as the first entry point
when you run the project so to run the
project what we will do that we will
just go to the command line and we will
say mvn spring boot run so let's do that
and let me open the terminal for that so
i have opened a git bash prompt here you
can also open the classic windows
terminal but this is something which git
installs by default if you install git
on your system it's pretty much exactly
the same it's just more unix-like but
it's also just a simple terminal shell
utility to access your file system so i
have gone to the project which we were
working with in the eclipse ide and this
is the path of the project so once you
reach to the path what you would like to
run is just say mvn
spring hyphen boot colon run that's it
and you hit enter once you write mvn
sprinkle hyphen boot call and run you
will see lot of code lot of logs here
where it is going to run all the compile
all the java classes run any tests if
there are any and then it is going to
start the web content application you
can see and once the application is
started you will get this message that
everything is run one of the interesting
thing which you can see here is that it
is also spinning up an application
server automatically for you and that
application server here which is being
used by spring is apache tomcat
technically apache tomcat is a servlet
container and it's not a full-fledged
application server but just to get the
point across you can use apache tomcat
as an application server which is being
used here
out of the box by spring if you don't
want to use apache tomcat and you want
to use something else you can do that as
well so now everything is ready and we
can now execute the application to
observe the output so for that let me
open a fresh browser window so that we
don't get any cached response and now i
can just type localhost 8080 and if i
hit entry enter i i get a white level
error page because there is no home page
for tomcat defined but there is a home
page for my application defined in fact
let's try to access the url which we
wrote in the greeting controller the url
was slash greeting so let's copy this
and let's put this here so
localhost8080
greeting and if i hit enter i get the
message hello world let me just zoom
this in a bit so that you can see so you
will see this hello world message here
by putting this url why do we see hello
world let's go back to the controller so
when you call this url this greeting
controller got invoked since we did not
provide any query string parameter the
default value which was world was picked
up and this world value was stored in
the name variable and the name variable
was added as an attribute to the model
and then we were using the greeting.html
and we were printing the name variable
since the name variable was holding the
value world so the message came as hello
world
with an exclamation and that's the
output which we see here now let's try
to supply the query query string
parameter the way you do that is provide
a question mark provide the key of the
query string parameter and the value you
want to put here so let's put simply
code as a value and hit enter so now the
message got changed and now it says
hello simply code so what happened here
is that whatever con query string
parameter we supplied that got passed
here at par as part of the request param
and the value of simply code got stored
in this name key and in turn in this
name variable and then i added the same
value into another name attribute and
added that attribute to the model so now
this name here is storing the value
simply code and then the all the things
work exactly is the same as i just
described it goes to greeting.html and
it prints whatever is stored in the name
attribute coming from the model let's
get started with spring boot and how we
can build a simple application using
spring boot before we go further let's
understand why we need spring boot and
the basic idea of spring boot is to
build restful web services if you want
to know more about what are restful
services please you can read about the
restful concept as a concept what does
rest stand for but the basic idea is
that if you are accessing anything over
http then that particular component can
be built as a restful component and
spring boot is the most popular choice
for building restful web services today
and even in fact microservices which you
might have heard about so you can build
microservices which also run on https
using spring boot so what i'm showing
you right now is the official guide of
spring which you can use to build an
application with spring boot it will
list down all the requisites which you
need in terms of the
jdk installations maven on and how to
complete this guide etc etc you can
again use the same springs initializer
which i talked about in the previous
session you can use this to generate a
spring boot project for you specifically
so all those options are available here
so i've already done that and i'm not
going to repeat what i just did in the
previous session and will directly jump
to an ide where i have created a sample
spring boot application and the
structure here you can see the structure
would look very similar with one change
that in the previous example when we
were dealing with mbc we had an src main
resources folder and that src main
resources folder was having all the web
components or the htmls but since in
restful web services you do not render
the html but you just send back the
response the response can be the
response body can be pure xml or it can
be pure json but you do not send back
and view and that's the main difference
between spring mvc and spring boot that
in spring mvc it will you are required
to return a view technology like in the
in the previous session we sent a dye my
lift template which is basically in html
you can also written a gsp but with
spring boot you do not deal with the
view technology and that's the world we
are living in today when you write
spring boot you do not have to worry
about how this is going to be rendered
on the web page whether it is going to
be rendered using html or whatnot what
you need to take care of using spring
boot is to return the right response
body the exact text of the response and
that's it so with that in mind the
spring boot was born and the structure
apart from that the structure would look
very similar there's a palm.xml here
which will provide all the list of jars
and dependencies which are required for
this particular project so you can see
all the dependencies here pretty much
the similar ones we have a starter web
we have a starters test and we have a
spring boot maven plugin and we have an
application file which is the entry
point again having a public static void
main method so you need to put the at
the red spring boot application at the
top of the class to make it an entry
point if you don't do this spring boot
will not run this class and spring boot
will
even not run your application so what we
are doing as part of this example that
we are just printing all the beans which
are provided by spring that's all we are
doing like i said it's a very
lightweight and the introductory session
so we will keep the logics to minimum
and i'm just getting all the bean
definitions sorting the bean definitions
and just printing them one by one how do
you get the bean definition you get that
with this application context class
which is returned when you run the
application and how you run the
application is basically using this line
where you say string application dot run
and you supply application dot
with any command line arguments which
you might want to use once you do this
it is going to return an application
context object to you and the
application context object can be used
to get all the bean definitions by
calling this method which says get bean
definition names so that's the basic
logic which is being run in the main
class now we also have a controller but
this time it's not a web controller but
it's a rest controller so you see in the
previous example we just had written
something like this it was just a pure
controller but here we have become more
specific we are saying that hey this is
not a simple mvc controller but this is
a spring boot controller or technically
a rest controller so spring provides a
separate annotation for that which is at
the rate rest controller so you write
that particular annotation or that on
the top of the controller class which
you are creating and then you provide a
request mapping similar to what we did
in spring mvc but while you return it
you do not return a view technology you
just return the raw response here i'm
just returning a string but you can
return a json object you can return an
xml object or whatever you want to but
not a view technology that's what i'm
doing like like you can see there's
literally nothing i'm doing in this it's
just a simple
string return statement which i have
printed here and that's all the code i
have right now here i just have these
two classes okay so that was all about
what i have written in the project and
now it's time to run the project so i
have just reached to the location on
inside my terminal where the project
bom.xml was present and if i just do an
ls you will see that there is a palm.xml
available here and all the code
directory is also available here so now
i will just run this application and to
run this application i'm just going to
type mvn spring hyphen boot colon run
and hit enter once i do that the spring
application is going to spring boot
application is going to get started and
let's go back to uh the controller and
actually the main app main end point and
see what we were doing there i did a cis
out here which said let's inspect the
beans provided by spring boot and then i
was printing all the bean names and if i
go back to the output i will see the
same line being written here which was
around let's inspect the beans so you
can see that message which says let's
inspect the beans provided by spring
boot and then all the beans which are
available in the application context are
printed here so that's that's the basic
idea which i want to give you that you
can actually build a spring boot
application and you can write your rest
controllers return a string body from it
and once this is run then you can also
run your application for from the web
browser as well so let's try to hit that
particular url which i wrote here so the
url of hello
so for that let me just open a new
cognito window and our application is
already running so if i just say http
localhost 8080 slash i get this message
here which says greetings from spring
boot and this is the message which we
were sending from the rest controller so
this validates our understanding that we
can invoke a rest controller which is a
spring boot rest controller via the same
method but this time we are not getting
an html but we are just returning this
particular string now you can use the
string in any ways you want so it
depends upon the consumer so that's all
i want to cover as part of the spring
boot now spring boot is a huge huge
topic and we can spend hours and hours
talking about spring boot but since this
is more of an introductory session so i
just wanted the concept to get
introduced and remember the value
proposition of why you would need spring
boot the basic idea is to build restful
web services or build restful micro
services that's the basic idea behind
using spring boot in your applications
and also remember the difference between
web mvc spring mvc application and
spring boot application spring mvc is
for building web application spring boot
is for building restful applications
which might not have a web interface
integrated with them at that moment so
that's all i want to cover for this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to have a look at
an advanced java project using some of
the concepts which we might have learned
during this whole journey and that would
be the last session of this particular
tutorial series let's get started with a
demo of a project which is using spring
boot to build a restful web service so a
restful web service is nothing but any
end point which you can access or you
can consume the data from via an http
layer or via a simply a web layer
because most of the web traffic which we
deal with is built on http so to take an
example if you go to any website where
you sometimes see on the top right
corner you see today's weather so how is
that today's weather coming in it's
coming in via a rest web service the
website which you are accessing is
basically hitting an http endpoint
which is uh where the where the weather
application is sitting and it asks for
the weather data and the dressed web
application just returns the data and
that's how the website is able to show
you the current weather so restful web
services are everywhere and they are the
most popular way to build applications
today where you just build your restful
web service and you expose an http url
and then the consumers need to just
access that http url to consume the data
from your application and you see this
makes it very easy because there is no
data type restrictions there is no tight
coupling here it's just an http endpoint
so that's the basic idea and we will
look at a project where we will be using
spring boot to build a restful web
service and then we will try to run that
web service to save some data and also
to return some data so here on the on
the package explorer you see i have
created a project called rest service
and let's just walk through the
structure of it and then we'll go into
the details of it so we have an src main
java where i have a package and i have
bunch of classes here and before we go
to the classes let's first also access
the dependency file because every
project needs some dependencies some
jars to execute it for example spring
itself is basically a jar so you need to
include the spring jar in your project
so that your project can become a spring
project and there are generally two
dependency tools one is maven and one is
gradle in this particular project i am
using maven or dependency tool for
downloading and managing the
dependencies which are needed to run
this project successfully and the way
you will find if it's a maven project or
if it's a gradle project for a maven
project you will see a file called
pom.xml
and if it's a gradle project you will
see a dot gradle file that's how you can
spot whether the project is using maven
for dependency management or it is using
gradle for dependency management so
let's open the palm.xml since it's an
xml file it will be a bit verbose but
if you just read it piece by piece it
will become easier to understand first
of all since this is a spring project i
need to include the parent dependency
which brings lot of good defaults
sensible defaults from spring boot
automatically and this is the jar name
this is the artifact id which is spring
boot starter parent so any spring boot
project you are starting do include this
parent this parent is basically bringing
all the dependencies from some other jar
and you can make your project as a as a
child of this particular parent so all
these spring
boot projects have this as a parent as a
standard practice after that you provide
your own details in terms of what is the
package name how do you want to see the
jar name on what is the actual name what
is the jar version etc etc you also set
the minimum required java version to run
this application and then you in the
dependency sections you provide all the
jars which you need to run your project
successfully both compile and run your
project successfully so we added the
spring boot starter web on dependency
which basically brings all the
dependencies around making a controller
or making a repository
context component scan all the
interesting features which spring
provides get wrapped up inside the
spring boot starter jar and you can
actually go to the mvn repository and
and have a look at what all classes it
provides it's a lot of classes so i'm
just telling you in a brief that it
provides all the restful functionality
then you have the next dependency as
spring boot starter data jpa which is
going to enable this project to also
have a database and if it has a database
then you need java to talk to the
database and the way spring suggests to
talk to the database is via using the
spring boot data jpa library we will see
this how this library can be used but
basically this provides ways to
represent your java object in the
database and then you need to also add
the actual dependency of the database
and in this case we are using an in
memory h2 database so i'm not using an
external database like mysql or oracle
or postql because that will just make
more configurations more complicated i
just wanted to keep it simple and
generally you in this h2 database you
can easily access by adding this
dependency and it will be an in-memory
database created for you then i've also
added a spring boot starter test here
which will be used whenever you are
writing unit tests and you must write
unit test for your project and then we
need to add the plugin so that spring
boot can run this project that's all i
have in the palm dot xml now let's move
to the interesting part the java section
part let's start from the main class
so this is how the main class looks like
where you have you just create uh any
any name with the class and then you add
a public static void main method inside
the public static void main method
you call spring application dot run and
this run method is basically going to
run your application and you just
provide the same class name which you
just wrote here so you just say dot
class and if you're supplying any
command line arguments it can interpret
that command line arguments as well if
you want so you'd always need an entry
point in an application and this is the
entry point which spring boot supports
and this is if you see this code this is
just normal code to make spring be aware
about this class being treated as an
entry point you need to add add the red
spring boot application annotation on
top of the class this is one of the
annotation which is coming directly from
the spring boot library you can see this
import so once you add this then only
spring will be able to treat this class
as an entry point otherwise spring
doesn't know where to start from so when
you run spring it will fi it will try to
find a class with an annotation
springboot application and then inside
the class it will try to find a public
start a static void main method and once
it has found both of them then it will
just run the application so very simple
nothing fancy here and what we are
dealing with here is a student object so
we will try to insert a student object
and we will try to retrieve the student
object so
if you ignore these annotations which
have added it's just a pure pojo it's
just a plain old java object you create
a student class let's ignore this field
as well for now i'll just come back to
this annotation in this field but this
is just a student class it has three
fields as name age and address an empty
constructor and a parameterized
constructor and some getters
intentionally i have removed the setters
because generally whenever you are
building any enterprise grid application
you would like to keep your objects
immutable means once they have been
created you would not like somebody to
allow to change the values of the object
this just makes programming much much
more easy if you treat all the objects
in your application as immutable that's
why i have not added setters here it's
just considered a good practice so apart
from the standard things which we have
already seen there are two things here
which i want to talk about let's first
talk about this one so accurate entity
is the annotation which is coming from
java x persistent entity persistence
entity and this makes
spring boot save this particular object
into the database this is the annotation
which you need to put on your class so
that springboot knows that this class
represents a table in the database so
you need to add this to make sure that
this represents a table second thing a
table will have a id it will have sort
of a primary key so i've created a new
column called id which is basically
representing the student's role number
or something or maybe a registration
number and here i'm using couple of more
annotations if you see these annotations
are also coming from java x persistence
library and these annotations will
basically allow the a new id to be
created every time you create a student
object so you don't have to specify the
value of this id variable springboot
will automatically generate a new id
value every time you create a new
student object and how does it generate
you you can provide the generation type
as well so currently i've just said that
set it as automatic but you can set it
as identity sequence or written or
controlled by table you can also see the
explanation of each of these here but
i've just kept it as auto which
basically
let the persistence provider pick any
appropriate strategy for the particular
database in our case the database is h2
so that's about the entity class let's
call this as entity class now let's move
to the repository so you need a
repository class
like i explained in dots in that three
tier architecture you always need a dow
layer or a repository layer to store
your student object into the database so
we have enabled the student object to be
saved but we need a handler which can
save this particular file this
particular object into the database and
the repository classes are the classes
which will allow you to do that so you
create a very simple interface you what
you name whatever you want to name your
interface as and then you say extends
jpa repository the type of the object
and the unique identifier of the object
so the type of the object is student
here and the unique identifier of the
student object is the id which is of
type long so you need to just supply the
types type of the object type of the
primary key or the type of the unique
identifier and this annotation is coming
from spring boot you can see
specifically spring boot data library
which we added so you just need to
create an interface extend it from jp
repository and make sure that you add
this annotation as well spring heavily
uses the concept of annotations and this
will help spring understand that this is
a repository layer class and it will
apply some more metadata to this class
while this class is running in the jbm
so what happens here you just created an
interface you did not provide any method
to create or any method to delete or any
method to get a student object because
all of that is automatically provided by
springboot via the jpi repository class
if we go inside this class and if you
scroll down you'll see the find all
method find all find all by id save all
flush save and flush delete etc and if
you go further up this also extends the
paging and sorting repository which
provides pagination and sorting
facilities but the interesting one is
that pages and sorting repository again
extends a crud repository and if you go
to the crud repository you will find all
the basic methods to save an entity save
multiple entities find an entity by the
id that's why it needed that long type
to make sure this that it can execute
this method you can check the existence
of an object find all the entries find
all by id count them delete them so all
the basic crud functionality so we call
them as crud because the reason it is
called crud because create read update
delete that's the basically the
generic acronym so because uh this cred
repository provides all the methods and
their implementations automatically we
do not need to write any code at all so
that's why spring boot is so awesome and
that's why springboard is very popular
because it's zero code in the repository
and you still get all the crud
functionality so that's about repository
now we have covered the entity class we
have covered the repository class we
have covered the entry point class now
the only thing which is remaining is the
is the
end point the http endpoint which i
talked about and that you can create by
creating any class generally try to
suffix it with the controller so that
your core developers can easily find
this class and make sure that you put
add the red rest controller annotation
on top of it this annotation will allow
string to treat this particular class as
an end point class then you can auto
wire the student repository so if you
remember i talked about the whole
dependency injection and inversion of
control so here dependency injection is
in action so here you are just telling
student controller to auto wire the
student repository and now what will
happen that at run time student
controller or actually spring will
automatically create an object of the
student repository and supply that
object of student repository to student
controller so you as developer do not
have to create an object of student
repository explicitly that's the benefit
and that's how the dependency injection
is working because you inverted the
dependencies now the dependency is just
injected into the class and as a
developer you don't have to take control
of creating the objects it's the spring
which will automatically read the auto
word annotation and will automatically
supply an object whenever it is required
then i have two methods here since we
are talking about http endpoints so i
have represented a post method here and
a get method here the way you will write
a post method is via at the ratepost
mapping annotation and then you can
provide the url path on which somebody
should call your end point to save
something so for example somebody can
call it http localhost 8080
student slash create whenever they hit
that url the control or that request
will directly hit this particular method
why because you have provided the url
mapping here in the post mapping
annotation so since it's a post method
there would be request body what is the
actual request body which the client is
sending and you can represent its uh
request body with the add direct request
body annotation and you can provide the
type of the request body and here i'm
saying that hey if you want to access
this particular url yes all good but you
need to supply me with a
text representation of the student
object or a json representation of the
student object and then i inside the
method i'm calling student repository
dot save which is going to save the
student object which is coming in so you
see there's lot going on here i will i
will show you how the student is
represented in the request body as well
and then i will come back to how it got
converted from json to java but this is
how you can store this particular
student object you can hit this api as
many times as you want and keep
inserting a new student object every
time then if you want to fetch a
particular student then you can do that
by supplying the slash student and then
in the curly braces there's an id
written here so basically you can supply
the value of the id of the student so
generally there would be another method
here which would be find all to see all
the students uh and with their id and
then you can pick a particular student's
id supply that student id value here
dynamically that's why at the curly
braces curly braces supports dynamic
value so here it can insert one two
three or whatever the student id you
want to fetch the value for you provide
that value in the student slash id and
all good then some if somebody is
hitting the url with saying localhost
8080
student slash 1 then student with the id
1 will be returned from the request and
you need to put admitted get mapping to
make sure that this method is treated as
an http get method and you can provide
the type you can say get student and
here this dynamic value is captured with
the add the rate path variable because
you need to know the id right whatever
id somebody has supplied it in the url
you need to capture that ide and then
use that ide for calling the repository
so that's you can do that by using the
add variate path variable so here i'm
just saying whatever id is coming in i
will store that value inside this ide
once i've done that then i can again
call student repository dot find by id
which is again a built-in method
provided to me by the crud repository i
can supply the id and this actually is
going to return an optional object which
is uh which is an object which may or
may not contain a value so it's a just a
types of a defensive programming style
so this will return an optional and you
can call a get method to return the
actual student object this will return
an optional of student so option of
student means that this optional object
may have a student or may not have a
student why did string do that because
the id somebody is supplying that id can
be invalid also right so optional object
3 takes care of that that if there is no
student found then you will not get a
null pointer exception and if there's a
student found you can return that so
it's just a defensive programming style
which string has adopted by returning an
optional of the student object rather
than directly the student object but if
you are confident that this particular
option of student object does contain a
student object then just call
optional.get which i've called here
which will return the actual student
object sitting inside the optional
object you can read more about the
optional object and its usage uh from
the official java docs and there are
tons of examples available on it on
internet so this is about the controller
we have covered all the classes now it's
time to run the application so you go to
the command prompt you go to the
particular
file folder location and there you just
say mvn spring hyphen boot colon run so
i just hit enter and this is going to
run the application it's going to split
some logs here and if everything is fine
you will not get an error and you will
just be getting a message saying that
application got started and it's running
on tomcat localhost 8080 with no context
url so this is not a web application
this is a rest full web service right
this is a restful service this is not a
web application so there is no web
interface so how do you access this you
just have an http url so you can use any
of the rest client available on the
internet there are probably hundreds of
different clients available on the
internet you can choose any one of them
i am using advanced rest client which
you can also install as an extension
from the chrome browser itself so if you
just if i just open the chrome browser
and i just say rest client if you just
write this and hit enter you will get
many different options and the first
option you get is from google play
stores app store so you can go to the
app store that basically the chrome web
store not the play store but the chrome
web store and you can just install this
since this is already installed you can
click on launch app and it will open
this interface for you so this is pretty
uh this is not a tutorial for advanced
risk client so i'll just be quick here
you can choose the method type which you
want to hit so let's say you want to do
a post and then you can provide the url
here so remember the url which we put
here in the controller method this has
to exactly match so http localhost slash
student slash create should be the url
so let me just copy paste this one here
okay so the url is good here it's a post
type of method which i want to do and i
want to hit this particular url now i
need to supply the content type and the
body so in the content type you can
choose application json because i'm
going to supply a json object and in the
body this is how the json object looks
like advanced risk client also provides
a nice visual interface to basically uh
create this json if you are thinking
that json creation is very tough it's
not actually tough it's just curly
braces and then you put key and value
key value comma let me just put an enter
here so that it's more readable so you
just put curly braces starting an end
and then you just put key value you put
a key which is the variable name and the
variables value variable name variable
value and these keys have to exactly
match the students properties so the
student.java had this name age and
address right so it has to exactly match
otherwise this will request will fail so
this is all good now i can send this
particular request when you click send
it is going to hit my spring boot
application which is running on
localhost 8080 it is going to call the
student slash create method it is also
going to convert this json into a java
object because here i am supplying a
java object so it will convert the json
which i'm sending from here to java
object automatically and it is going to
automatically save it here because i've
called the repository.save method so
let's hit send here once i hit send i
get a 200 okay it means everything went
fine and in the response header i get
the object back because i have returned
the object here you see this save method
is going to return the same student
object which you created uh so
everything is good here my object has
been stored here and now it's time to
fetch the object so it has already been
saved into the h2 in memory database and
you can obviously go and connect to the
in memory h2 database and have a look at
it but for simplicity i'm just gonna do
this here and let's say the first object
is generally
added as the id one by default by the h2
database so let's hit this particular
url when i hit this url it is going to
hit the student controller here and in
the student controller it is going to
hit the get student method which is
having a student id url and it is going
to find the database with that id and if
it finds a student object with that id
it is going to return that so let's
confirm that now let's hit this
particular send button and it's going to
hit a get request with this particular
url springboard is going to find if a
student with the id 1 exists in its
database
so once i hit send i get a 200 okay and
you see in the response headers i get
the same student object back which i
added let's try with two now let's see
what happens i see two and i get 500
internal server error because there is
no object stored in the h2 database of
the spring application with the id 2 yet
because we only inserted one object
that's why only one student object is
there and the first id which h2 database
created for it automatically was one so
when you hit for get request with a
student id one you get the object when
you put any invalid value and you hit
this you get a 500 internal server error
you can also make it look nice by not
sending the 500 internal server error
and sending a nice exception from the
back end so from here you can also send
a nice exception that if this object is
not found you can say something like
that or else throw which is again an
optional object and here you can supply
a particular type of exception which you
want to supply instead of just throwing
500 internal server error but that's
just additional thing additional
defensive programming you can do you can
add more and more validations and
constraints into this project as you
build this project in a more complex
paradigm so this is basically what i
wanted to show you that and that we have
created a spring up boot application we
have connected it to a database we
haven't created also an http endpoint
with student controller we ran that
application we used any random rest
client in my case i used advanced stress
client and we first did a post request
we provided the exact url the url has to
exactly match with the controller url
and then the body the request body also
has to exactly match with the student
objects property especially the case of
the names have to exactly match so if
this all this matches then you will get
a response back that the object has been
created if you want to fetch the value
of the object you're going to use the
http get method and you again provide a
url which has to exactly match to some
method in some controller in the spring
boot application which is running on
localhost and if you provide the right
id you are going to return get a valid
result if you provide an invalid id you
are going to get a 500 internal server
error and from here on you can make this
controller as robust and as mature as
you want you can add find all method you
can add a update student method you can
add a delete student method you can have
all different kinds of filters like for
example return to me all the students
starting with the name a or return all
the first
students with the role number one and
hundred or between 100 so you can write
as many endpoints as you want and build
this application in
as with as much maturity and as much
complexity as you want and that's all i
want to cover in this particular lecture
thank you and we'll meet again in
another session and with that we have
come to an end of day 5 of software
development i hope this session was
informative and interesting
on day 6 of software development we will
explore a whole new and powerful
programming language that has the
potential to take a head-on head
competition with java and is simple and
easy to learn at the same time yes you
guessed it right the python
until next time thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe to stay tuned
for more from central
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you